[Music]
all the way
around
the house will come to order members
take your
seats
just keep
[Music]
going
the household come to order the chair
recognizes the member from Auburn
representative Osborne who moves a house
adjourned from the session of March 15
20122 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by house chaplain Reverend Bob
Stewart pastor of St Paul's United
Methodist Church in
Manchester
good
morning let us be in a spirit of
Prayer in the middle of this week oh God
assure us again of your presence in the
midst of Our
Lives renew our strength and
determination to do your will here on
Earth even as it is done in Heaven
above guard and protect us from
experiencing a sense of self contentment
and from having a vision that may be too
narrow enable us to reach outside this
chamber into our
communities and even stretch us further
beyond our
communities may we somehow become your
agents of
change May those changes be for the good
of all people here in New Hampshire and
even some corner of this anguished world
we again come to you in prayer today
with hopes that through our Collective
and unified prayers we might see an end
to the war against
Ukraine we also ask for prayers for the
Russian people who are caught in the
middle of this
war oh God you created and breathed life
into all of
humanity every life is precious to you
and in turn every life should be
precious to to each of us as
well oh god of love and peace I pray you
will be with each member of this house
and I pray that you keep your guiding
and watchful hand upon each of them
guide them and help them to make sound
decisions for the people they represent
and to make sound decisions for the
State of New
Hampshire I pray that your guiding hand
upon each member will give them the
courage and strength to guide their
hearts in doing what is right and just
for all
people keep them all safe and healthy oh
God and free of any
harm we also ask that you be with all
the leadership of the house keep your
hands upon them as they lead this
body oh god of the Alpha and the Omega
may we be your hands and feet in this
world and again we ask that you keep
help us us to be your agents of change
it is in your glory and honor we pray
this day and every day
amen the chair recognizes a member of
Portsmith the dean of the house
representative Laura panacis will lead
us in a pledge of
allegiance the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
na
God indivisible liy and jusice for
all the chair recognizes a member from
maror Lucius parcel who will now perform
our national
[Music]
anthem
for
[Applause]
thanks house will
attend to request for Le of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Burch Cleaver Ellis Mary
Griffin Hopper Jack Kimbell lton
Littlefield lungren Miler Newton salaway
sopus Tudor Veil the day important
business Representatives Cody Crawford
Harvey the day illness in the family
Representatives Davis and
Elliot these leaves of absence shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house the house will come to
water the house will
attend to introdu ction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome for I
don't believe they're in the gallery uh
we have no
guests Welcome to the New Hampshire
house the house will
uh
house will now attend to the house will
now attend to the continuation of the
regular calendar beginning with House
Bill one 332 the committee on
education
e
the
can I have everyone's attention for a
minute
we have a slight malfunction it is on
its way up so we'll be in a short recess
until we can get this straightened
out
I would start over
speaker I hav I
haven't I haven't even read it
yet members take your
seats
e
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill
1332 an act accepting public
universities and colleges from
requirements under medical freedom in
exonizations having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate presentive Glenn cordelli
from The majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sentive Linda Tanner for the
minority of the committee chair can for
what reason does a member rise good
morning Mr Speaker I Rise to make a
motion State your motion to table
1332 it is a proper motion the motion
before
us the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1332 this will be a division vote
members take your seats roll call who
requested a roll call
representative kushman requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your
seats
the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 1332 on the table this is a roll
call vote
the chair recognizes representative luno
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know parents expect public
and private colleges to take reasonable
steps to protect the health and safety
of
students and if I know I want to hear
the debate on how this bill will better
enable public colleges to protect our
kids who go there make New Hampshire's
colleges more attractive build our
Workforce and grow our economy then
would I press the red button to defeat
the tabling motion thank
you g recognizes representative Lang for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that every
citizen has a natural essential and
inherent right to bodily integrity and
free from threat or compulsion by
government to accept an immunization and
we have affirmed that right just last
year at the passes of hp220 the
underlying law that this bill seeks to
amend Mr Speaker if I further know that
this bill seeks to make a subclass of
New Hampshire citizens where that
natural essential and inherent right
would be taken away and Mr Speaker
lastly if I want to protect all New
Hampshire citizens reaffirm that natural
essential and inherent right to bodily
Integrity free from threat or compulsion
from government would I now press the
green button and support the tabling
motion has everybody turned on their
machines
they ain't ain't going to work if you
don't turn them on when I hit the
button the motion before us is to lay
House Bill 1132 on the table this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the
vote 172 voting yay 142 voting aay House
Bill 1132 is late on the
table
majority of the committee on education
to which was ref referred House Bill
1355 an act requiring scholarship
organization to refer suspected cases of
misuse of funds or fraud in the
education Freedom account program the
Attorney General having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that as inexpedient
to legislate presentive Glenn cordelli
from The majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and be enable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sen David luno from the the
minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise I Rise to make a motion State your
motion to table
1355 that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table House Bill
1355 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I POS
nay the eyes have the eyes have it House
Bill 1355 is laid on the table
majority the committee on education to
which was referred House Bill
1367 an act relative to Civic instru
instruction in schools having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment of Glenn cordelli
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Linda Tanner for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0933 printed in house record 10A Pages
53-
54 are you this the question is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the amendment
is adopted the question before us now is
on the committee report of ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted majority the committee on
education to which was refer referred
House Bill
1376 act relative to partici
participation in the education Freedom
accounts program by students with
disabilities having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution that resolved it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Deborah Hopson for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senate Patricia
Cornell for the minority of the
committee what reason does a member I
Rise to make a motion State your motion
to table 13
76 it is a proper motion this motion
before us is a table House Bill
1376 roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
so
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 1376 this is a roll call
vote the chair recognizes representative
Mullen for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that informing parents about
the rights of their specialed students
should be a priority for all of us and
if I know that the Department of
Education contributed to the drafting of
this bill would I now push the red
button against the tabling motion so
that the debate could continue thank you
chair recognizes representative Hobson
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that in committee we learned all these
Provisions in this bill are already in
Rule and if I know we have many bills to
get through this week would I now press
the green button thank
you the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1376 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
w MERS presentent an
[Music]
opportunity
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to the state of
the
vote 179 voting a 153 voting nay the
motion to table
passes
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1381 an act relative
to student school board members
considered the same report the same with
a recommendation the bill ought to pass
Senator Alicia leakas for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted this is going to be a roll call
vote we have no debate we just have
piis representative n has requested a
roll calls that's officially
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
members will take their
seats
oh that's right Jo majority of the
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1434 FN an act
relative to the availability of school
curriculum materials having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment pres of Rick lad for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the major majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative Sue Mullen from
the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0992 printed in house record 10A page 58
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say
I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted and the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
1434 this is a roll call vote
J recognizes representative Mullen for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that Provisions already exist
under RSA 186 colon 11 for parents and
Guardians to review curriculum materials
in a timely fashion and request
Alternatives and if I know without any
demonstrated need that this bill would
extend the opportunity Beyond on parents
and Guardians to any Resident in a
community and require unspecified staff
to gather indeterminable amounts of
course materials within a 10-day window
and if I believe that the policies and
procedures already in law are adequate
enough to address any concerns what I
now oppose the recommendation of ought
to pass as amended by pushing the red
button so that another motion may be
made the chair recog as representative
sandborn for a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that
parents taxpayers and residents have a
natural right to know what is being
taught in their schools and if I know
that this bill simply honors this right
and requires curriculum materials to be
made available within 10 days of the
request would I then now support New
Hampshire parents and ensure
transparency and public education by
pressing the green
button
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass as amended onh
House Bill 1434 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
abson
all members president had an opportunity
to
vote
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote El will attend to the state of the
vote 185 voting yay 152 voting a
committee report is
adopted
majority committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 1564 FN local an
act requiring school districts to
provide breakfast for students having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Senator
Deborah Hopson for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the rec recommendation that the
bill ought to pass sen Arthur Ellison
from the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative Ellison speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to the itl
motion on HP
1564 there is no disagreement that
students who participate in breakfast
program programs have better School
attendance and higher academic
performance than those who are
hungry all of the research on this issue
supports those conclusions the committee
heard comments during the hearing on
this bill that if students came to
school hungry is the fault of the
parents this perspective does not
reflect the reality of some students
lives some of whom are homeless others
who are living in Dysfunctional Family
situations and it is not fair to blame
the actions or in this case the
inactions of parents on their
children feeding our children should be
one of the highest priorities of our
schools in this case the 30 school
districts that do not currently provide
breakfast to their students and finally
it's a sad commentary on our priorities
when we need legislation in order to
feed children but that's where we are
now thank you Mr
Speaker do I recognize the
representative Hopson to speak for the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker in the
education hearings we learned that of
466 schools taking advantage of the
school lunch program only 30 were not
already providing breakfast if this if
this measure were to pass schools would
need to expand offerings to comply with
the provisions of this bill likely
increasing costs at an amount
indeterminable some of the costs to the
Department of education are start up to
uh cost to start up the program and
Personnel to oversee and run the program
these functions are currently not funded
and as a result would violate the New
Hampshire Constitution Article 28a as an
unfunded mandate with only 30 schools in
New Hampshire not participating in the
program it would seem to be a matter of
choice over costs for these reasons I
would request you support the itl motion
thank
you
the question before us is the itl motion
on H Bill
1564 are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
members will take their seats this will
be a division
vote
for
the motion before us is the majority
report of any speed to legislate and
House Bill 1564 this is a VI division
vote the chair recognizes representative
Woodcock for a parliamentary
inquiry good morning Mr Speaker and
thank
you if I know that New Hampshire
currently ranks 47th out of the 50
states in in our nation school lunch
participation in each day New Hampshire
Miss is serving
7,869 students School breakfast and
annually leaves on the floor or table
$1.5 million of food Federal funding
money and if I know research supports
that student from food and secure and
modally secure households get more of
their food nutrients from school school
meals than any other student and if I
know the research d that supports
students who have more nutritious diets
tend to perform better and pay more
attention in the school and finally if I
know this bill was wisely sponsored and
co-sponsored by several Republican
Representatives then we should follow
their lead and vote no on the itl so a
more food fill option can be
discussed chair recognizes
representative Ford for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill changes
School requirements from providing
students one meal a day to mandating
that they provide both breakfast and
lunch and if I know that this would
apply only to the 30 districts that do
not currently provide
breakfast and if I know this is a 28a
issue that will cost thousands of
dollars for those 30 districts would I
now itl this unfunded mandate by
pressing the green
button thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before us is the majority report of any
speed to legislator and House Bill 1564
this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
e
representative
Marsh while members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to state to the
vote under 180 voting nay 160 voting nay
committee report is
adopted
majority of committee on education to
which was referred House Bill 1576 FN
act repealing the law relative to
certain discrimination in public
workplaces and education we considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Rick lad
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee every
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass s of Sue Mullen for the minority of
the
committee for what reason does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to make
a motion State a motion to table
[Music]
1576 the motion before us is to table
house house bill 1576 a roll call has
been requested as as officially second
this will be a roll call vote members
take their
seats
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1576 this will be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative Mullen
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the pro prohibition
against teaching discrimination in
public workspaces is about censoring
public employers and programs from
sharing historical information that
questions the status
quo and if I know that our country was
founded on the principle that speaking
without fear of reprisal is essential
and guaranteed and if I believe that we
have a responsibility to defend the
First Amendment would I now press the
red button to oppose the tabling motion
so that another motion could be made
thank you J recognizes representative
lad for parliamentary inquiry thank you
Mr Speaker if I know that discrimination
of any kind is unacceptable in public
workplaces and education and if I also
know the New Hampshire Department of
Education has launched launched a new
web page in support a New Hampshire
Commission of Human Rights aimed to
ensure that students and educators are
free from discrimination and that they
have the opportunity to learn and teach
in a safe environment and lastly if I
believe this new law provides a unique
opportunity for the department and all
school districts to have a meaningful
conversations about discrimination and
to better understand and differentiate
between discrimination and
non-discrimination would I then support
the tabling motion by pressing the green
button the motion before us is a table
House Bill 1576 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
Spain representative
Spain thumbs up or thumbs
down you have to give me a thumb up or a
thumb
thumb down thank
you
while members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 186 voting yay 158 voting nay
committee report that lane House Bill
1576 is laid on the
table
members stay in your seats this is going
to be another quick
one majority of the committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill 1607 FN an act prohibiting unlawful
discrimination in public and non-public
schools having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to
legislate Senator Glenn cordelli for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
to being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Linda Tanner from the
minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise I Rise to make a motion stage
motion to table
1607 proper
motion representative Tanner has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
1607 this is going to be a roll call
vote the chair recognizes representative
Tanner for parliamentary
inquiry hold on
representative is that it
no if I know there we go if I know that
hb67 extends the New Hampshire
non-discrimination law and equal
protection to all schools tuition
programs and Educational Services
receiving State funding and if I know
that the State Board of Education should
have the responsibility to ensure that
all students in New Hampshire in
protected classes as defined in New
Hampshire law are shielded from
discrimination and if I know that Public
Funding requires public accountability
and that's why we need to hear this
debate would you please vote against the
tabling motion thank
you the chair recognize representative
cordelli for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that we
are making progress getting through the
calendar today if I know that the
director of The Human Rights Commission
testified in our committee that this
boat would complicate And Delay
discrimination complaints processing and
investigations and if I know that this
bill would effectively remove the
constitutionally protected exemptions
for religious organizations would I now
vote to get on with our business so that
we don't have to stay here until 400
a.m. on Friday by pressing the green
button the motion before us is to table
house
bill
16007 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Bailey we're in the voting mode members
stay in your
seats representative
Simpson
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote well we thought you were out
representative thumbs up or thumbs down
representative thank
you all members presid had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state to the
vote 189 voting yay 155 voting aay house
bill 16007 is laid on the
table majority committee on education to
which was referred House Bill 16 32 FN
act relative to civil rights education
in public and Elementary and secondary
schools considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study pres
Alicia leak is for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with a majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate sen of
Linda Tanner for the minority of the
committee what reason and does a mem
rise I Rise to make a motion stage
motion to table this bill
1632 is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table House Bill
1632 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those opposed
nay eyes have it in 1632 is laid on the
table
majority the committee on education to
which was referred House Bill
1638 an act relative to grievances under
the right to freedom from discrimination
in public workplaces and education
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to
legislate Alicia Le is for the majority
of the committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass pres of Linda Tanner
from the minority of the
committee what reason does a member rise
I Rise to make a motion stage a motion
to table
1638 the motion before us is the table
1638 House Bill
representative luno has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your
seats
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1638 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Tanner for a parliamentary inquiry
members should be in their
seats thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill will bring a local
procedure for discrimination claims in
schools and if I know that this bill
provides a way to bring local Solutions
and local remedies for discrimination
claims that will help bring Civility and
respect rather than division to our
schools and if I know I am here today to
do my job to sit and listen to debates
and to allow a debate like this on a
very important issue would I press the
red button so that we can have the
debate we're supposed to have thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Alicia leas for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that once again this
repeals language
um protecting people protecting our
students from
discrimination and if I
know that this bill mandates that the
parents first go to the
superintendent and if the superintendent
is the one that is initiating the
Discrimination the parent has nobody to
go to and will be afraid to go because
they will be afraid of recrimination
against their children um would I then
press the green button thank
you the motion before us is a table
House Bill
1638 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
repr
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 190 voting yay 1522 voting nay
House Bill 13 638 is laid on the
table the majority committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill 1639 act relative to youth risk
behavioral survey in schools having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment sen of Ralph bone
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Su Mullen
for the minority of the committee the
amendment is
0189 H printed in house record 10A Pages
82 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay
guys have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us is majority
report of a to pass as amended the chair
recognizes representative Mullen speak
against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise in opposition to the house Ed
majority recommendation of ought to pass
as amended to House Bill
1639 relative to the youth risk R
Behavior
survey the yrbs has been used as an
instrument to capture student voices
since
1993 for 29 years it has provided
confidential data regarding student
atrisk behaviors to schools law enforce
and Community agencies so that they may
develop and deliver programs that speak
directly to student
needs currently any parent who does not
wish for their child to participate in
the
yrbs only needs to notify the school and
the child will be
Exempted that is detailed under RSA
18611 along with the requirements for
Parental notification and the required
opportunity to review the
document house bills
1639 seeks to flip the process and
require that any parent who wishes their
child child to particip participate
provides written
permission on the surface this may seem
like no big deal but the reality is that
anyone who has ever had to collect
permission slips knows that even for
highin activities like field trips films
and sporting events hectic lives and
forget forgetful children often result
in paperwork being left on the kitchen
counter without a permission s there
would be no
participation the impact of inadequate
participation those most affected had a
lot to
say House Education received impassion
testimony from many stakeholders the
National Alliance on Mental
Illness the Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence new Futures the
Franklin New Hampshire Chief of Police
the Raymond Coalition for youth the
Stafford County substance misuse
prevention coordinator and our own State
of New Hampshire Public Health Services
director pointed out that the data
collected by this
survey allows them to secure funding and
address topics such as
bullying Suicide Prevention substance
misuse violence harassment vaping
anxiety depression and more
to a person they po pointed out the
benefits to communities from the
targeted responses that guide them in
knowing what individual communities need
and to a person they talked about the
potentially devastating impact of not
being able to survey the minimum number
of students required for the data to be
considered
representative excuse me and unbiased
their programs and services are at risk
of
elimination you may hear testimony today
that kids don't take this survey
seriously and that may be true for a
few you may hear that the yrbs is
considered a joke by some again
possible but what about the kids that do
take it
seriously how many kids have we helped
maybe even saved because we listen
to
them instruments like the yrbs have
metrics built into them to account for
the responses that are obviously
untrue the outliers get tossed so that
the results are reliable and not
skewed there is nothing funny about drug
and alcohol abuse or
suicide there's no joke in sexual
violence anxiety and depression or being
the victim of
bullying there are tough issues
addressed in the youth risk behavior
survey without a doubt because these are
the real issues that are challenging our
kids we heard testimony from experts in
the field that when participation moves
from opt out to optin data and
requirements are affected and programs
are
eliminated questions remain if not the
tried andrue yrbs how will we go about
Gathering the data to know what we
should be doing do we guess are we going
to be required to shift the expenses for
current programs onto our
constituents what kind of messages are
we delivering to our youth when we
silence their voices because the topics
are too tough to talk
about for these reasons I ask that you
press the red button against the ought
to pass pass as amended recommendation
so that another motion may be
made thank you we're down to the last
speaker representative Mullen has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this is going to be a roll call
vote members take your
seats the chair recognizes
representative
B
thank you Mr
Speaker some years ago I introduced a
bill to put a rain in on non-academic
surveys parents had to be notified and
questions provided Bill finally passed
and is now law even though there have
been multiple tries to change it
everything was opt out except for the
Youth risk behavior
survey however at this survey is taken
as a joke by most high school students
when I was on the school board this was
given in our high school I heard from
students that they were taking this as a
class project to see how bad they can
make it how many times do we get
drunk do you take drugs and then and
they asked answered on how to do it some
Weeks Later our principal came to our
high school our school board meeting
with the disasterous results I then
informed them how the survey was taken
our student School Board member verified
this other schools have the same issues
when they know the survey is being taken
social media goes rampant but entries on
how to answer the questions we had
testimony with this testimony at our
hearing also parents need to know what
their children are being asked parental
rights all questions on any survey must
be given to parents so they can make the
decision to allow their children to take
the survey
over the years we've heard arguments
that parents do not get the permission
slip for the survey so they do not opt
in interesting parents have to opt in
for field trips these seem to be
returned parents don't opt in because
they do not want the child to take it
and nowadays this is also being done
electronically emails Etc to parents so
it's not hidden in the school bag some
now some may testify that this survey
and others are all academic it is a
schools responsibility to teach not be
social workers these only these surveys
only interfere with the student learning
activities for example in the CTE
committee that I'm on it came out that
some Career Tech education students may
miss their courses because the surveys
be taken at their resident school and
it's been proven time after time that no
survey is anonymous the first seven
questions on this survey one can easily
determine who is answering the question
questions age grade grade sex race
height weight Etc then there are
questions on using drugs anyone guess
who will answer correctly if they
are and questions on drugs drinking sex
suicide can also serve as training AIDS
we've seen this in the past with some
drug programs and why they have been
stopped parents need to know again what
questions are being asked for their
children If the parents are specifically
has to opt in then they will take the
opportunity to check the questions and
at what percentage Point does it make
the Ser the survey immaterial if only
some are answering correctly remember
this survey is done by the CDC and
depending on what administration is in
power questions do become political in
the past there are questions on guns in
home now I bet this year there'll be
question of vaccinations another
argument is that they need the entire
school to take the Serv survey to get
the full results what's the do
difference students answering at a joke
or not answering at all so please press
the green button thank
you the motion before us is the majority
report of art to pass as amended this is
a roll call vote members will be in
their
seats
e
chair recognizes representative Cornell
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that I have no idea how to
counter the amount of misinformation you
have just been given and if I know
and if I know that numerous stakeholders
testified that they relied on the data
collected by the youth Behavior survey
to plan programs and services to address
bullying suicide anxiety substance abuse
and more and if I know that surveys and
tests have built in metrics to account
for the very small number of students
that may not take it seriously and if I
know that I was in a school when
students were taking this risk survey
and I don't know of very many at all
that said oh I'm just going to make a
joke out of this and if I know that
after spending 36 years in education
that optin does not work even for a
great field trip because kids are
forgetful and if I know that I spent
hours in the morning before a field trip
calling parents for their crying child
to please run in with that permission
slip would I now vote no and press the
red button so another motion could be
made for future parliamentary inquiries
and for future speeches I'm going to ask
that all the members adhere to what we
try and observe in this chamber that we
do not try and put blame or suggest that
somebody else has a bad motive or of
anything of that nature so please please
I'm talking to both sides of the aisle
here for what reason does a member rise
for an inquiry of the chair you may
inquire
Mr Speaker isn't there a
difference between maligning and
questioning
motive and what I heard which was a
concern about
facts the member in my opinion suggested
that the member
lied
now I that I why I'm addressing ing both
sides of the aisle
here we've had it before we've had it
yesterday and it's already started today
and I'm asking all the members to
refrain from making any type of an
accusatory remark about another
member you may further
inquire thank you Mr Speaker and I I
appreciate the explanation and agree
with it entirely my concern is that
there is a difference between the word
misinformation which simply means a
mistake and disinformation which implies
a lie thank
you thank you
for the chair recognizes representative
Alicia leak is for a parliamentary
inquiry uh before you start
representative yesterday we I asked also
that we keep our parliamentary inquiries
to parliamentary
inquiries they're starting to get a
little bit long I'm not referring to you
right now representative but they're
starting to get a little bit long on
both sides of the
aisle so please keep your parliamentary
inquiries to what they should be a true
parliamentary inquiry not a
speech thank you Mr Speaker if if I know
that false information can lead to false
results and we're based in um and then
we would be basing actions on false
results and if I know that uh many
parents object to this survey and if I
know that some that most School District
websites are so large and so complicated
then even if notification is given on
the website the parents May well not
find it and even know to be able to opt
out what I now press green thank
you the motion before us is a majority
report of ought to pass as amended on
House Bill 639 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 183 voting yay 164 voting nay
committee report is
adopted for what reason does November
Rise um just I'd like to request the
remarks from the prior debate be printed
in the permanent
Journal okay everybody calm down the
motion was made to have the remarks
printed in the permanent journal from
the prior
debate are you ready for the question Mr
Speaker does that includ your remarks
on
okay and first first of all when any the
house will be in order
first of all any questions points of
order will the member has to come down
to the podium unlike the last two years
where are in off-campus from now on the
member must come down to the podium and
ask the question and to answer your
question uh the the it is part of the
remarks and it yes it would be included
in the permanent
Journal
division has been
requested members will take their
seats
hold on hold
on
[Music]
e
the motion before us is to print the
remarks in the permanent journal from
the prior debate this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the rest red button voting
stations are open for 30
[Music]
seconds
going
representa
represent
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house attend to state of the
vote 240 voed y 106 voting nay your
marks will be
printed
screen
we're going to we're going to take a
quick recess we still got some IT issues
going on so we're going to take a five
minute or so
recess
so we can get going
again
e
Teresa members take your
seats
the house will be in
order the house the house will be in
order recognize the clerk Mr Speaker and
a letter from the chair of the criminal
justice committee pursuant to house rule
47f as chair of house criminal justice I
hereby wave off the second committee
assignment of House Bill
11:30
majority committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 1669 FN an act
requiring the Department of Education to
administer the education Freedom account
program having consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
Pres Michael Moffett for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass pres of Steven Woodcock for the
minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative lad thank you very much
Mr Speaker I Rise to make a motion State
your motion to table
1669 is a proper motion the motion is to
take T
1669 representative luno has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call
vote
for
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1669 the chair recognizes representative
luno for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if if I know New Hampshire's
160,000 public school kids perform among
the best in the country and that's what
parents want and if I know this bill
would have the Department of Education
manage
the state's Voucher Program returning
millions of dollars every year to
education and if I know that I want to
hear the debate on how this bill would
actually increase voucher funds by 10%
instead of it being pocketed by a
contractor with current and former State
reps on their board then would I press
the red button so that we can hear the
debate on this Bill thank
you chair recognizes representative
morfett for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that Abraham Lincoln that
guy if if I know that abraam Lincoln was
was correct when he
advised against Changing Horses in the
middle of a
stream and if I know that the education
Freedom account program is in its
infancy and it's way too soon way too
early to pass judgment regarding current
program administrative structure and
finally if I know that the department of
education does not seek and is not
prepared to suddenly take over the EFA
program Administration then would I
press the shiny Dartmouth big green
button to support the tabling resolution
thank you Mr Speaker the motion before
us is the table House Bill 1669 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote under 185 voting yay 158 voting nay
House Bill 1669 is laid on the
table majority of the committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill 1670 local an act relative to funds
of the education Freedom account program
after termination of a student's
participation responsibilities of the
scholarship organization having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate sen of Deborah
Hopson for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sen of David luno for the minority
of the
committee what reason does a member rise
I Rise to make a motion State your
motion to uh table
1670 the motion before us is to table
House Bill 16
70 are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
members take their
seats we have no parliamentary inquiries
so it will be a moving to a quick
vote
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
1670 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
repr
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend state to the
vote 188 voting yay 163 voting nay House
Bill 1670 is late on the the
table majority of the committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill
1672 an act relative to misuse of
Education Freedom account funds having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator valicia
leak is for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unble agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass sen of David luno from the
minority of the
committee the motion before us is the
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1672 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose
nay guys have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred 1683 FN local an
act repealing the education Freedom
account program having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Glenn
cordelli for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass represent David luno for
the minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative
Porter speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Mr Speaker and good
morning again colleagues I have a few
definitions here for you this
morning according to Ed choice and I
think most of you know who Ed choice is
it's not a
man School
vouchers give parents the freedom to
choose a private school for their
children using all or part of the Public
Funding set aside for their children's
education according to BR britanica
proon this is a site the Encyclopedia
Britannica puts up issuing you know
debating pros and cons of various
issues Britannica proon says School
vouchers are state or School District
funded scholarships that allow students
to attend a private school of the
family's
choice and according to Ed Choice 18
states and DC had one or more voucher
programs Arkansas Florida Georgia
Indiana Louisiana Maine Maryland
Mississippi New Hampshire North Carolina
Ohio Oklahoma Tennessee tenee Utah
Vermont and
Wisconsin and according to the Cambridge
dis dictionary a school voucher in the
US is a scholarship that allows a
student to attend a private school
rather than a public
school in the words of The Bard AR Rose
by Any Other
Name New Hampshire now has the most
expansive School voucher program in the
country the house will be in order and
yet this body has never had a chance to
listen to a debate and vote on the
provisions of the bill which established
it hb20 the house version of the program
raised so many concerns it was retained
in committee for further work but the
Senate rushed ahead and any way and
included their similarly flawed version
of in
hb2 we have been told that bills
attempting to fix this Myriad of ills
and we've heard many of them today this
week are a cruel attempt at Death By A
Thousand
Cuts and that those proposing such bills
were members of the education
establishment cared nothing for the poor
or the harm done for
children despite the fact that most of
us have spent our entire working career
it's 40 years for
me our working lives loving and
teaching
them so this is what we
have a program that is wildly unpopular
with the general
public a program that lacks
accountability administered by an outof
State company which gets to decide who
is approved who gets funded and what
qualifies as an educational expense with
lax rules passed over the objections of
the professionals responsible for
advising us on rule
making a program that allows
organizations receiving public funds to
discriminate against against those they
don't approve of a program that may
leave students and taxpayers susceptible
to Fraud and
Abuse a program that could bleed the
state dry financially because there are
no budget caps no limits on how much can
be spent in just the first few months
it's already nearly $9 million over
budget and
growing the LBA has warned us us that if
all eligible students not currently
enrolled in public schools not enrolled
in public
schools took advantage of the program
the cost to the state could be $70
million a year I'm going to say that
again these are for all the kids out
there that are eligible for this program
now if they all applied next year that's
the figure LBA is
estimating to and this is new spending
this isn't money we're spending on
education now talk about a Thousand Cuts
that's a
hemorrhage we have tried to fix it
you've heard us try to fix
it the only option available now is to
repeal it please let common sense and
your sense of frugality Prevail and vote
no on this itl motion thank
you
representative luno has requested a roll
call we're coming down to the final
speaker is that sufficiently seconded is
sufficiently seconded this is going to
be a roll call vote we're down to the
final speaker so members take their
seats chair recognizes representative
cordelli thank you Mr
Speaker the voucher plan is nothing less
than an attempt to dismantle our public
schools and replace them with private
schools
we've heard that argument about the new
education Freedom account program but we
first heard it back in
2011 with the debate about the tax
credit scholarship program the same old
proven false
argument and since we're on the topic of
Education we don't have a voucher plan
the states mentioned uh all have voucher
plans opponents can't get that right
maybe we need a lunch and learn program
about uh education
freedom and why are why are opponents so
scared of the education Freedom programs
I REM am reminded of a quote competition
is always a good thing it forces us to
do our best a monopoly renders people
complacent and satisfied with
mediocrity in a 2019 analysis of studies
of the impact on Act academics of choice
programs on public schools 24 studies
showed a positive effect of school
choice on the public schools one neutral
and one negative so why are people
scared over 1,800 students are enrolled
in the program and remember these are
lowincome students due to a family
income cap of 300% of federal
poverty but HB
1683 would repeal and throw those kids
out of the program what about them are
they just collateral damage yet
opponents say shut it
down when we're talking about funding
point out this is the only program of
its kind that has a phase out of funding
for students leaving a public school the
first year after they leave the school
gets 100% of State funding plus all
local funding the second year they get
50% of State funding and all local
funding and the third year they get
25% of State funding and local funding
the year after that they get all local
funding
still The Minority Report says that it
is the responsible thing to do to repeal
this program
responsible ask par parents how
responsible it
is yes again opponents are scared scared
because this program is successful yes
more students selected efas than
originally
estimated and why is that why is it
above en rollan estimates well the
pandemic opened a window into education
and the parents have taken notice a
parents are standing up against those
who say they should not have a role in
their children's educ ation parents are
standing up for Education options
parents are standing up and so should we
and we will we will stand up for
families and children we will stand up
for Education opportunities for New
Hampshire children we will stand against
this repeal we will out itl this
outrageous attempt to destroy this
program if children are our future we
must must provide them with educational
opportunities to be successful we will
not fail these students and we will not
fail the
future I'll be in
order this is a roll call
vote members will be in your
seats
the motion before us is a majority
report of inex speedi to legislate on
House Bill 1683 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizing representative luno
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know New Hampshire's 160,000 public
school kids perform among the best in
the country and that's what parents want
and if I know the state's voucher
program is the most expansive voucher
program in the country and is riddled
with flaws and if I know that the
program is clearly not as successful as
some proponents may suggest given that
the vast majority of the voucher
students maybe around 200 um I'm sorry
vast majority of of students maybe maybe
around 1,600 were already attending
private schools and homeschooling
situations and if I know that this bill
is the only option left since every
other Bill to improve the financial
responsibility accountability and to
prevent fraud has been defeated and if I
know this bill will repeal a program
that steals from taxpayers and is ripe
for fraud and misuse then would I press
the red button to overturn the itail
motion so another motion can be
made chair recognizes represent of
Osborne for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker so if I
believe
that every child is entitled to an
adequate education but I know that a
one-size fits-all program system cannot
possibly provide it to every child and I
know that this legislation before us
would tear almost 2,000 children away
from their chosen environment and return
them to the inadequate educational
environment from once they came would I
now press the green button for the
children house will be in
order the motion before us is the
majority report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1683 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
represent hson
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house liend to stay to the
vote 109 V 189 voting yay 166 voting nay
committee report is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker can I move that the
remarks from the previous debate be
placed in the permanent
journal the motion before us is to print
the remarks of the previous debate in
the permanent journal without
objection without objections they will
be
printed uh representative seaworth
declared a conflict of interest and did
not participate in the
vote what reason to member rise Mr
Speaker I ask that house bill 1072 be
removed from the table and I ask my
colleagues to vote
green criminal justice from
yesterday
update dis
put it up
please put it up
please
e
Teresa what was the amendment number you
remember
the
you're good
to
okay the motion before us is to take
House Bill 1072 off the table I'm going
to read it again majority of the
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred House Bill
1072 an act establish ling a criminal
penalty for denying an elected School
District official access to any school
district facilities documents or events
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment s of Terry Roy for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred House Bill 1072 and
act establishing committal penalty
having considered the same report the
same being un agree of majority Report
with the following resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Ray Newman from the minority of the
committee seeing that we didn't adopt
the amendment before the amendment is
0893 H printed in house record 10A Pages
10 are you ready for the question on the
amendment we have we have the division
to remove it from the
table
we weren't we already already got
that the motion before us is to remove
it from the table on House Bill 1072
this is a division
vote members need to be in their
seats I have nothing
down I understand that if you want to do
one we'll do
one I did say we can't do it I said we
don't have
one he wants to do a
pi
okay the chair recognizes
represent the chair recognizes
Representative Steven Pearson for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that having the the
amendment put on this Bill gets rid of a
lot of the problems and we weren't able
to do
that and if I know the debate and
discussion on the situations that led up
to this are important to hear would I
then press the green button to remove
this from the table thank you
sir chair I recognize the representative
Conley for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this bill makes all
student records including special
education PL
and private Personnel records available
to budget committee members and
Schoolboard
members and if I know it would give
these same elected officials access
to entire school buildings including
locker rooms whenever they
wish and if I know this bill threatens
arrest to any school official who
violates the law would I press the red
button to keep this bill on the table
where it belongs thank
you
motion before us is to take houseu 1072
off the table this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
have all members president had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to the state of
the vot
vote 177 voting y 180 voting nay the
motion
fails house will be in
order
so this debate is on the
amendment I will let the body know that
we are finally done with
education majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred C
ac15 an act relating to elections
providing the age to vote in the primary
election be reduced to 17 for those who
will be 18 by the general election
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment president Wayne
McDonald from majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same been unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexp to legislate sen of Connie Lane
for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0735 H printed in house record 10A Pages
1 and
two the chair recognizes representative
lebranch to speak against the committee
Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
honorable colleagues I rise today to
oppose the committee Amendment on cacr
15 the underlying cacr as titled as the
title would suggest would allow for
17-year-olds to vote in the primary
elections if they are 18 by the general
election I oppose this amendment for
multiple reasons first it completely
guts and replaces the bill secondly I
believe that the underlying bill would
actually pass with B with a bipartisan
majority as the underlying bill was
actually
sponsored by the majority whip and the
member from londondary Who currently
serves as the chair of state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs back in
2015 it was also sponsored by the
members uh by other members back in 2019
most notably the member from gtown Who
currently serves as the chair of the New
Hampshire young Republicans the
underlying cacr is also supported by the
New Hampshire leg legislative youth
advisory Council while the amendment is
opposed by the council that is why I ask
all of you to vote down this amendment
so that we can debate the substance of
the underlying Constitutional Amendment
and pass it with a triartisan majority
thank
you g recognizes representative barara
Griffin thank you Mr
Speaker and thank you to the
representative for bringing the issue
before the body because it is always um
great to learn something new about
proces in the house because once a bill
goes to a committee it is the Committees
and we know that in all of our
committees that we as committee members
then control what goes forward in a
bill whether it is related to the
original subject or not after a hearing
on what amendments might be non-g
and that is indeed as you just heard
what happened in this
amendment this representative from
gtown didn't think that the underlying
Bill had much chance of success before
the
house and this representative from
gtown often disagrees with other
representatives from gtown and that is
the point of this debate of this Hall of
this
microphone
so the amendment that's brought before
you is to raise an issue for your
consideration indeed about elections
about voting and who should be voting in
them I actually disagreed that it was
non- gerain but we followed the process
and that is the bill that is before you
today and I ask that you support the
amendment so that we can have a debate
on the underlying issue that is Before
You Now by by the majority vote of the
committee thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
committee Amendment
0735 H are you ready for the
question although a division has been
requested members will take their
seats
who who's requesting a roll call Senor
Barry requests a roll call is that
sufficiently it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
oh
the motion before us is the vote on the
amendment to cac1 15 this is the vote on
the
amendment this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e represent
fedus
speak all members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to state to the
vote 192 voting yay 163 voting a
committee amendment is
adopted the motion before us now now was
ought to pass as amended chair
recognizes representative
Lane to speak against the committee
report is it on thank you Mr Speaker the
majority stated purpose in the committee
of this C this amendment as amended the
cacr is to place the current statutory
definitions of Resident residency and
domicile into the Constitution so that
it will be harder to change them in the
future the minority feels that this cacr
is
unnecessary precisely because these
definitions are already in the
statutes but more importantly if we are
going to amend and put these definitions
into the Constitution then let's do it
right the language should be drafted
thoughtfully and carefully so as not to
create more confusion about an issue
that this body has argued about for
years and in court if ped there will be
five qualifications to vote in New
Hampshire you must be a citizen of the
United States you must be a citizen of
New Hampshire you must be domiciled in
New Hampshire New Hampshire must be your
primary residency and you can only vote
where you are
domiciled so let's look at the second
and the fourth requirements both of
which introduce undefined terms into the
qualifications to vote in New
Hampshire nowhere are the terms primary
residency or citizen of New Hampshire
defined not in the
cacr and not in the statutes the term
primary residency implies that there
might be a secondary residency or other
types of
residency and what does it mean to be a
citizen of New Hampshire how is it
different from being a citizen of the
United States must you be a citizen of
the United States to be a citizen of New
Hampshire is New Hampshire going to
start issuing passports as one who
testified on the cacc
inquired this cacr creates creates
necessary confusion and will actually
prolong the debate over the definitions
of domicile and
residency and if passed in its current
form no not only will be it more
difficult to amend the bill but it will
insert even more uncertainty into the
already protracted debate regarding what
domicile means Visa resident thank
you
representative Barbara Griffin has
requested a roll call we're down to our
final speaker is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this is going to be a roll call vote we
are down to our final speaker members
take your seats chair recognizes
representative Barry thank you Mr
Speaker I'll keep my remarks brief to
cacr so it requires
2/3 uh Mr Speaker the election law
committee is attempting to put to bed
the endless debate in New Hampshire over
who should vote in a New Hampshire
election the old domicile residency
state of mind we're trying to put that
to bed Mr Speaker we are saying that if
New Hampshire is your primary residency
you get to vote here we asked people
testifying about this bill how many
people do you think this will stop from
voting in New Hampshire election they
said well realistically none why because
you should already be a resident if you
are voting here voting is an active
residency so Mr Speaker this is a common
sense reform and the question before us
is who should vote in a New Hampshire
election residents of New Hampshire or
residents and non-residents of New
Hampshire so Mr Speaker if you believe
that non- residents should be voting in
New Hampshire elections oppose this Mr
Speaker if you believe that only
residents of New Hampshire should be
voting in New Hampshire then you should
vote
green the motion before us is the ought
the majority ought to pass as amended on
CAC R15 this is a roll call
vote members be in your seats chair
recognizes representative Mirad for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker yeah if I
knew that cacr 15 should be would not
resolve ambiguities uh could the
representative just suspend for a
minute good to go thank you Mr Speaker
if I knew that cacr 15 would not resolve
ambiguities but would actually introduce
new
ambiguities into the venerable New
Hampshire constitution of
1783 and if I believed that cacr 15
might impede ballot access for voters
who move frequently because their
housing is insecure would I press the
red button so a new motion could be
made chair recognizes representative
Barbara Griffin for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this legislative body in multiple
prior sessions has considered bills for
statutes which can be changed by this
body addressing the qualification of
Voters and if I know that the New
Hampshire Constitution provides for
domicile qualification while in statute
at this time domicile and residency have
been defined and made equivalent and Mr
Speaker if I agree that having these
terms in our constitution is important
today and in the future to make sure
that only legally qualified persons of
New Hampshire are voting in New
Hampshire would I now press the green
button thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before us is the majority report of a to
pass as amended on cacr 15 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 second
seconds
I mean it
[Music]
would repr
Roy
speak all members present had an
opportunity to
vote also attend the state of the
vote
we had 190a 165 Nays it did not meet the
three F requirement of 235 so the motion
to pass
fails State your point of order what is
your point of
order we're voting on whether or not to
adopt the amendment not on the cacr per
se we already voted we voted on the
Amendment and this was on the ought to
pass as amended I apologize for my
confusion I asked remarks on this debate
be printed in the permanent
Journal we would need a separate
motion for printing the remarks you Rose
for a point of
order and I have a feeling it's coming
uh M speaker am I allowed to speak State
your motion um motion to uh print the
remarks in the journal the motion before
us is to print the remarks in the
journal without
objection without
objection this next one is a division Pi
so stay in your seats all right if
everybody will stay in your seat the
next bill is a division with
parliamentary inquiries
only majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred CAC
r19 an act relating to paper ballots
providing that all elections should be
conducted through paper ballots having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass s of Katherine prud M Bryan from
the majority of the committee minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority report Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Russell Morhead for the minority of the
committee this is
a represent representative Maguire
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your
seats
wel
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass on cacr 19 this
is a roll call vote the chair recognizes
house will be in
order chair recognizes representative
mad for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I
knew that current law already does what
this cacr proposes to
do which is to require that New
Hampshire elections be conducted using
paper
ballots and if I knew that in public
hearings before the election law
committee the committee learned of no
one who's suggesting that that current
law in this respect be changed in any
way and if I believed that this cacr in
practice would function to validate
unfounded fears that New Hampshire
elections lack
Integrity rather than functioning to
solve real problems would I press the
red button so a new motion could be made
thank
you J recognize representative to Roan
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that paper ballots are vital
in any election for any recounts that
may be
requested if I further know that a paper
trail Left Behind from a paper ballot
can survive long after a memory card has
been wiped clean clean would I then Mr
Speaker codify in New Hampshire
Constitution part 1 article 11 the
following
requirement article 11a paper ballots
required for purposes of facilitating
the examination and recounting of
votes cast all elections shall be
conducted using paper ballots and
finally if I know voter Integrity is
important to the citizens of this great
state what I now press the green button
to vote Yes and support the committee
recommendation of autop pass thank you
Mr
Speaker motion before us is the majority
committer report of a to pass on CAC r19
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos to press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Abramson
Cen Mr
Speaker all members present had an
opportunity to vote also will attend to
state to the
vote 195 voting yay 160 voting nay
committee report failed
for State your point of
order Mr Speaker um on the last cacr uh
it was not a two-thirds majority and you
had said the report was accepted
no I said the motion
fails majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill
10009 an act requiring the date a person
registered to vote to be included with
other voter information having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass of Joe Sweeney from the majority
of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with a majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate
reprentative Paul berson from the
minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative berson to speak against
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1009 would require
that the date of person registers to
vote be included with other V vo
information in election net that's being
done now and it's been done since 2006
when the state launched the Statewide
voter registration database which was
required under the federal help America
vote act there's a field titled date of
voter information which is the date of
voter
registration right now the date of
registration is confidential if the bill
passes the date of registration will
still be
confidential the data fields that are
printed on a checklist under state law
now are name domicile mailing address if
different from domicile and party
affiliation the bill does not require
that the date of registration be printed
on the checklist so what will this bill
do and here's the problem prior to the
launch of election net towns and cities
maintain their own voter registration
databases whose primary purpose was to
generate the checklists that would be
used at the polls since the date voters
registered to vote wasn't needed to
print the checklist that information
wasn't contained in the
database so the bill creates an unfunded
mandate there's no Grandfather Clause
here in 2006 our towns and cities
migrated approximately
825,000 voter records into election net
most did not include the voter's
registration date since there's no
Grandfather Clause the bill will require
that communities scour their databases
ident identify the pre2 2006 voter
records in election that do not have a
date of voter registration pull the
paper record and then key in the updated
voter registration
information article 28a of the
Constitution prohibits the state from
mandating any new expanded or modified
programs or responsibilities to any
political subdivision in such a way as
to necessitate additional local
expenditures house bill9 would require
that election officials bear the cost of
keying in data for the pre2 2006 records
without providing a means to reimburse
the communities for their costs in doing
so please press the no red button to
overturn the committee recommendation so
that another motion can be made and Mr
Speaker I request a division
vote chair recognizes representative
Sweeney speak for the committee
report right thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker House Bill 10 09 is a simple
bill that adds to the checklist
available to the public the date a voter
registers to vote knowing when people
register to vote and having that as
public information can Empower granted
stators to have a clear view when
considering policy the Secretary of
State's office largely has this data for
most voters I don't disagree about the
pre 2006 voters um but there and we will
continue as a state to collect this
information as we go forward as new
people are added to the voter
registration roles there's nothing
nefarious or unto about this legislation
as proposed there's nothing wrong with
putting this information on the
checklist as we've described it is
simply another data point added to a sea
of data points that will enable the
political parties candidates and the
public at large to have a greater view
of the voter registration process and
who and when people are registering to
vote I urge you you all to vote in favor
of our majority ought to pass
recommendation on House Bill 109 thank
you representative Christian the roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
this will be a roll call
vote
for
[Music]
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass on House
Bill read that
10009 this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative Hamlet for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
date of voter registration is
confidential and exempt from the right
to no law and if I know that this
legislation is not needed for candidates
in political organizations to
effectively get out the vote would I
then press the red button to defeat this
motion so another motion could be made
thank you
chair recognizes representative
Alexander for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
hb19 helps to shine a light on elections
by making the date of vote voter
registers public and if I know the
Secretary of State's office largely has
this data for most voters and will
continue to collect information and
record it on voters going forward would
I now press the green button to support
making public information actually
public thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the autop pass
majority report of autop pass on House
Bill
10009 it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Canon
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 185 voting a 167 voting a committee
reports
adopted we're going to take up one more
bill
and then we're going to do our
lunch jority the committee on Election
law to which was referred House Bill
1082 an act prohibiting certain State
offices from forming political action
committees having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass sen of
Katherine pred home O'Brien for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator Paul
berson for the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative berson to speak against
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker this bill
would prevent candidates who seek to run
for Secretary of State or state
treasurer from forming political action
committees in their
name not somebody else's name but in
their name since a 1976 Supreme Court
ruling the right to participate in
democracy through political
contributions has been protected by the
first amendment in its ruling the court
said that quote virtually every means of
communicating ideas in today's mass
Society requires the expenditure of
money the distribution of hand bills or
leaflets entails printing paper and
circulation costs it costs money the
electorate's dependence on these
communications for information has made
these modes of contact indispensable
instruments of effective political
speech end
quote I received one of these flyers
that cost money uh on the way in to the
chambers yesterday and uh it actually
summarizes quite well the point that I'm
trying to make uh standing here at the
podium today it refers to House Bill
1082 and it says this bill limits
political speech by prohibiting
candidates for Secretary of State and
State Treasurer or current office
holders of these positions from forming
a political committee or political
advocacy organization or soliciting
contributions for such
organizations it continues part one
article 22 of the New Hampshire
Constitution states free speech and
Liberty of the press are essential to
the security of freedom in a state they
ought therefore to be inv viably
preserved end quote and it finals it
ends with its position limits on all
speech in particularly political speech
may be a tempting solution to a
perceived problem but it is not a proper
solution during the public hearing on
this bill and in the majority
report the sponsor cited the quote
nonpartisan nature of these two offices
as just as
justification for these fundraising
restrictions I don't think I need to
remind you that all our town and City
elections are nonpartisan in nature too
um I hate to open the door to think that
we wouldn't be able to have packs in our
names if we were running for for
election or
reelection finally this bill would have
a severe impact on the ability of
candidates for Secretary of State and
State treasur to gather the financial
resources needed to effectively
communicate with those who will cast
votes in those elections and would POS
in restrictions restrictions that our
state and our federal constitutions
cannot
tolerate please press the red no button
to overturn the committee recommendation
so that another motion may be made and
Mr Speaker I request a division vote
does the member yield to questions uh he
does yes the member does
yield uh thank you um you know it it it
may surprise people to hear this I'm I'm
still actually undecided on this bill
and I have a technical question that I'm
I'm
hoping you can sort of enlighten me on
um as most of us are probably all aware
uh in New Hampshire we we Define pack
and candidate committee separately and
um I can't find an answer if this bill
includes candidate committees in
addition to a regular pack or if it's
only referring to a regular
pack thank you for the question um based
on my limited knowledge of campaign
Finance laws I consider a pack and a
candidate committee the same thing in
terms of filing reports with the
Secretary of State's office does member
yield a further question no further
questions member does not
yield chair recognizes representative
royan McDonald speak for the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker this legislature and its wisdom
made the office of Secretary of State
and State Treasurer nonpartisan in
1997 when it amended rsa1 14 col 2-
B while I didn't have the honor of being
a member of this body back then I I
understand that at least part of the
reason for having done so was because
these offices are not partisan in nature
and really should not be political in
nature the political aspect of New
Hampshire elections is handled by our
two great political parties and should
not in any way be found in the
Department of State along that same line
the administration of State finances
should not be a political matter but a
sensible professional and
straightforward
one I understand the contention that
municipal candidates all over the state
are also nonpartisan and can and would
still be able to form packs even if this
bill were passed however they are
seeking the votes of thousands of people
and are popularly elected while we may
call our decisions on Secretary of State
and State treasur and elect ction what
they really uh amount to are
appointments by a government body
candidates for these constitutional
officers are seeking the support of only
a few hundred New Hampshire is one of
three states in which these officials
are elected by the state legislature and
not by the general electorate in Maine
one of the other two states forming
packs is prohibited by those who would
seek and serve in these Offices in
Tennessee the third state the concept is
viewed as so inappropriate that no one
does it on an occasion in recent years
when such a pack was formed in New
Hampshire it was similarly received with
disapproval the best example of the need
to maintain the integrity and
non-political nonpartisan nature of the
Secretary of State's office in
particular is the legacy of former
secretary William Gardner secretary
Gardner a lifelong Democrat served this
state well for four and a half decades
and was elected repeatedly by both
Republican and Democrat majorities in
this
legislature he was so elected and
reelected because of his his effective
Fair even-handed management of New
Hampshire's
elections allowing candidates for
Secretary of State and State Treasurer
to form political action committees
would dangerously and unnecessarily
inject politics and possible conflicts
of interest into these important offices
and do so to the disservice of New
Hampshire citizens I urge you to support
the majority ought to pass
recommendation of the election law
committee thank you Mr Speaker does a
member yield the questions I do not
member does not
yield this is a division vote members
will take their
seats
e
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass as amended ought
to pass on House Bill
1082 this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative Mirad for
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I knew that this bill would
make it impossible for persons who were
interested in serving as the Secretary
of State or the state treasurer to make
their names known to the citizens of the
state and to make their qualities known
to the citizens of the state and if I
knew that public
ignorance of those persons who are
interested in serving as Secretary of
State and treasurer would undermine or
diminish Democratic accountability and
and might Empower
insiders then would I press the red
button so a new motion could be
made the chair recognizes representative
P prol O'Brien for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Mr
Speaker if I know that in Maine a nearly
identical Bill to this was passed after
that state suffered from Corruption of
their Treasurer in the mid1
1990s and if I
know that there's a full month between
when we are elected and then
organization day a full month that
candidates for treasurer or Secretary of
State can call us or email us contact us
come to our house they don't need a
political action committee for that they
just need a telephone or an email
address or a or or an auto automobile
would I now press green to support the
committee recommendation of autop
pass the motion before us is a majority
report of aop pass on House Bill
1082 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Bernardi
hold
on all members present
voted also attend the state of the
vote house will be in
order 177 voting yay 176 voting nay the
speaker did vote to break a tie
committee report is
adopted I have two lunchtime
[Music]
announcements
representative
dosi
the house the house house will be in
order oops
okay ah
there uh first of all I would like to
apologize
for oh my
mask my mask how's
that first of all I would like to
apologize for my faux paw yesterday uh
when I inadvertently walked uh in front
of the Diaz
um that was a mistake it was a senior
moment and since I'm only
39 uh that's surprising but it happened
so please accept my
apologies
um the other announcement I would like
to make is that the secular values
legislative caucus is meeting today uh
in the um conference room in the clerk's
office and this is for all people in the
chamber religious or non-religious and
it's basically about uh discussing our
if you're committed to secular values
then we would like to see you with the
caucus and have a nice lunch and
discussion thank
you chair recognizes representative
langing for an
announcement 1 two 3 four there we go
thank you Mr Speaker first off
representative the bean please calls
your wife she texted me your phone's off
number two um remember we're doing our
food drive for through April 10th um
every pound of food we collect we have
some sponsors who are going to be giving
us money for our two Charities which
will go to support domestic violence
prevention program and a veterans
homeless veterans relief program so if
you're coming in tomorrow remember
there's boxes in the back there's boxes
here there's boxes over at the lob
please bring in some food drop it in
there so we can get some pounds and get
some money for our Charities thank you
the
clerk clerk has an announcement thank
you Mr Speaker I was asked by our
custodial staff um last night after
session many members uh left dirty
tissues filled water bottles and other
various sorts of trash on the floor in
the chamber please if you hike it in
Hike It Out secondly uh just a a very
firm reminder reminder again if you do
not vote in the 30 seconds your machine
is shut off do not attempt to push it or
beat it up after the 30 seconds have
ended I will call your name and you need
to give me a thumbs up or thumbs down
thank
you we'll be in recess until
1:5
the house will come to
order majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill
1153 an act relative to absentee ballot
requests having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
the bill ought to pass so appe corosion
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate pres Paul
berson for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
Bon thank you Mr
Speaker this bill proposes to amend RSA
657 col 12 relative to absentee voting
the statute currently states that quote
upon receipt of a properly executed
application for an absentee ballot a
town or clerk shall ascertain if the
applicant is on the checklist and if so
the clerk shall send the materials end
quote this bill proposes adding the
following sentence to that statute quote
under no circumstances shall a town or
city clerk mail an absentee ballot
unless and until such person has
submitted a absentee ballot application
the town of clerk has approved the
application end quote in short the bill
says the same thing that the statute
already
says no substance is being added to the
statute that isn't already there among
the principles of good legal writing
unnecessary or extra word should be
removed redundancy should be avoided and
different words should not be used to
say the same thing House Bill 1153 is
poorly crafted adds nothing to existing
law and is totally
unnecessary please press the red no
button to overturn the committee
recommendation so that another motion
may be made and Mr Speaker I would
request a division
vote a division vote has been requested
we're down to the last speaker members
take your
seats chair recognizes representative
quy for to speak for other committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker this legis legislation proposes
a change in RSA 657
col2 to clarify and reinforce the
requirement that absentee ballots may be
mailed to absentee voters only after an
absentee ballot application has been
received and approved by the town or
city
clerk the necessity for this
clarification was demonstrated by
testimony before the election law
committee which revealed that some
clerks include the actual absentee
ballot when resp responding by mail to
request for voter registration forms and
absentee ballot
applications the result is that some
unregistered applicants receive absentee
ballots before becoming a registered
voter and before their absentee ballot
applications have been properly
certified members appreciate that as
clarified by this legislation clerks
will have to perform two mailings one to
send the application forms and one to
send the absentee ballot however the
majority of the election law committee
believes that the requirement is
worthwhile to ensure that registrations
are processed before a registrant is
provided in absentee ballot this will
enhance election
Integrity by preventing official
absentee ballots from going to
unregistered voters who that may not
have the right to vote in New
Hampshire I therefore respectfully
request that you press the green button
to vote Yes on the aut toass motion as
recommended by the majority of election
law committee thank you Z belaro has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
motion before us is the majority report
of autop pass on how House Bill
1153 this is a roll call
vote the chair recognizes representative
berson for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that nothing is being added to the
statute that isn't already there and if
I know that the absentee voter
registration and absentee balloting
process described by the previous
speaker appears in a different statute
if I know that house bill 1153 is poorly
crafted redundant and totally
unnecessary would I then press the red
no button so the subsequent motion may
be made thank
you chair recognizes representative bar
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that during testimony on this
bill a town clerk admitted to mailing
ballots actual ballots Mr Speaker to
unregistered voters people who were not
on the voter roles actual ballots would
I now Mr Speaker press the green button
so such a practice can no longer take
place the majority report is ought to
pass as a ought to pass on House Bill
1153 house will come to
order this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
if all members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 185 voting yay 158 voting nay the
committee reports
adopted
majority the committee on Election law
to which was referred House Bill 1203 FN
act relative to dile residency voter
registration and investigation of voter
verification letters relative to the
terms resident inhabitant residency and
residency having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
Fenton groan for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Senor Paul Bon
for the minority of the committee the
amendment is
0962 H printed in house record 10A pages
19- 26 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those poose nay yes
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as amend last minute
Amendment does not accomplish that the
bill retains a two-tiered voter
registration system which the court
found was
unnecessary and it introduces new
confusions that will invite new
litigation for example a person who
registers to vote 30 days or less before
an election and who doesn't have proof
of residency can sign an affidavit if he
acknowledges that his domicile may be
verified a person who registers more
than 30 days before an election does not
have that option they cannot sign that
residency affidavit instead they sign
one in which they're swearing that quote
they will not ever be able to possess
any qualifying documents of domicile end
quote if I were homeless I sure wouldn't
want to swear under the penalty of fines
that I would be forever homeless but
here's another example and this is a
true story and it's the kind of
situation that often occurs with new new
residents to our
communities just before I retired as
City Clerk in Nashville came a woman
came into our office uh she happened to
uh I happened to be the one assisting
her at the counter she and uh she had
just gotten married a couple of weeks
prior she and her husband had come in
for the marriage license about a month
prior to that previously she lived in
tingor her husband lived in nashille he
was renting a condo in nashwa so after
they were married she moved in with them
the lease was in his name all the
utilities were in his name and she
wanted and needed to get a New Hampshire
driver's license because she needed to
do that within two months of moving to
New Hampshire she brought her marriage
certificate along with a copy of her
husband's lease and her husband's
utility bill because nothing had been
changed over yet both of which had her
husband's name on them and when she
tried to get a driver's license she was
refused the person at DMV actually told
her that the marriage certificant didn't
didn't prove that she lived with her
husband at that
address so she wanted to register to
vote to have proof of where she
lived now I knew that they had come in
they had got the license I knew her
where her husband lived I had no
problems whatsoever of registering that
person to
vote of course I can't do it if this
couldn't have done it if this bill was
in effect because she had no physical
evidence of domicile and could not swear
that she would quote not ever be able to
possess any qualifying documents at
domicile she was not would not be
eligible to register to vote under this
law as it's
written another litigation concern the
voter registration form for Citizens
registering to vote 30 days prior to an
election uh states that the applicant
has to swear that to make that he has to
make the address I have entered above my
domicile for voting I must have an
intent to make this the one place from
which I participate in Democratic
self-government and must have acted to
carry out that
intent I have no idea what must have
acted to carry out that intent means the
expression is undefined
unexplained the minority is concerned
that the bill will make ballot access
more confusing and difficult for some
citizens to register to vote and the
courts will end up having to weigh in
again because we rush through this
amended bill it needs more work please
press the red no button to overturn the
committee recommendation so that another
motion May be made and Mr Speaker I
request a division
vote Jeran as representative Gro speak
forther committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1203 was introduced to remove
language from the RSA that is no longer
used because of a Supreme Court decision
and to restore some necessary language
that existed in the RSA prior to that
decision however HB 1203 as introduced
as in introduced would have weakened the
domicile residency requirements for
voting in New Hampshire for example 654
colon 1 the section that deals with the
person's claim of domicile was amended
to add a person's claim of domicile for
voting purposes shall not be conclusive
of the person's residence for any other
purpose Amendment
962h amends HB 1203 to replace all after
the enacting clause as amended HB 1203
removes the language regarding voter
registration forms and voter affidavits
that is no longer used because of the
Court decision and it restores some
language as I mentioned that existed in
the RSA prior to the court
decision this language is supported by
the Secretary of State's office I also
added it this bill also adds language to
strengthen and clarify the forms and
process processes used for registration
prior to 30 days before an election and
the forms and processes used for voting
within or registering within 30 days of
election or on Election Day the intent
of this language is to ensure that every
qualified New Hampshire voter has a
right to register and vote it is also to
assure to the best we can that persons
who are not qualified to vote in New
Hampshire should not be allowed to vote
in New Hampshire and thereby dilute the
vote of those who are qualified to vote
in New Hampshire I urge you to support
the election law committee's
recommendation of ought to pass with
Amendment a division has been requested
this will be a division vote members
take your
seats
clear
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto passes amended
on House Bill 1203 chair recognizes
representative Horgan for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
um before I start the pi have a very
quick question was I was under the
impression we were going to have a floor
fight over the amendment which you're
you're recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry okay so the uh real par in Korea
is trying to make us out of order that's
fine thank and thank you Mr Speaker if I
know that the hb123 as amended is so
poorly drafted it's hard to tell exactly
what it does even after I've reread it
several
times but if I was able to discern that
this amendment does not protect the
right to vote and does not simplify the
voter registration process and in
general does pretty much the exact
opposite of what myself the prime
sponsor of this bill and the co-sponsors
intended
and um so find out so would I then
representative you're recognized for
parliamentary inquiry yes I
I I thought I was thought I was giving
one so if I know that this amendment um
does not do with the sponsor is intended
would I then press the red button so
that an alternative motion can be um can
be considered thank you Mr Speaker do
you I recognize the represent Barbara
Griffin for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill has amended makes changes to our
election laws that will make them
consistent with what the practice is
making them easier for persons to
understand and if I know that this
amendment continues to allow for
affidavits of proof of Eligibility to
include domicile for persons registering
on Election Day and for certain quality
qualifications 30 days before and
finally if I know that this legislation
does not create any unreasonable burdens
on the right to vote would I now press
the green button thank you Mr
Speaker motion before is majority
committee report of Auto pass as amended
onh House Bill 1203 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
e
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to stay to the
vote speaker you got to read the thing
he he he closed it out
before
the vote is 185 y 163
Nays it was it was clo it was closed out
before the button was
pushed committee report is
adopted
okay if everybody will stay in their
seats we have a division with just
parliamentary inquiries majority of the
committee on Election law
to asked who asked for the roll
call majority of the committee an
election law to which was referred House
Bill
1247 an act relative to folded ballots
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator Paul berson for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with a
majority Report with a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Peter to Roan for the
minority of the
committee a roll call has been re
requested by representative blazic is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote the motion before us is the
majority report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1247 recognizes representative Peter ter
Roan for
a yes for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know House Bill
1247 would require that in any political
subdivision that uses electronic ballot
counting
machines
any ballot that has been folded by uh
any ballot that has been folded uh be
held for counting after the polls close
and if I know the Windam audit found
that some folded ballots were not read
properly by B ballot counting machines
due to a shadow uh created by the fold
rending the scan are unable to
accurately score the
results Mr Speaker I further know that
we would never have known the rail
antenna of those voters if an audit had
not been
performed if I believe there's reason to
think this can happen under other
circumstances and if I know towns
already hand count ballots when there's
a right in candidate on the ballot and
that works just
fine and finally if I know that this
legislation would add an additional
measure of security by requiring all
folded ballots to be hand
counted when I now press the red button
to overturn the itel motion to ensure
that every vote counts and return
confidence to voters that the New
Hampshire
legislature take seriously the
responsibility to safeguard the election
process red button please thank you Mr
Speaker J recognizes representative
hammer for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that hand counting ballots after the
polls close will add another four to
five hours to the 14-hour day already
put in by our overworked election
workers and if I know that one-third of
the ballots cast in the 2020 general
election were folded
ballots and if I know that the
committee's bipartisan majority knows
that the local moderators already have
the authority to direct that absentee B
bot be tallied by hand and the decision
be should be left up to the discretion
of the local election officials would I
now vote Yes and push the green button
to keep the bill as itl thank
you the motion before us is a majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
1247 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
no
representative
algro I heard
you
representa
H representative
hlin
representative
HL all members president had an
opportunity to
vote I guess I don't need to say house
will attend to the state of the vote
203 voting a 145 voting a committee
report is
adopted
mik is this
suckets
e
chair recognizes representative Weber
for a
motion thank you Mr Speaker
Representatives Weber and Griffin rot
move that in light of the changing
season and increasing warmth in the
chamber the gentlemen be able to remove
their jackets except when speaking at
the
well are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppos a
eyes have
it committee on Election House will be
in
order
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 1264 establishing
rank CH voting for the state Party
primary elections and Municipal
elections representative Reed moves
moves ought to pass and offers
Amendment
099 h on page
3637 in record
10A
and the chair recognizes representative
Barbara Griffin to speak
against Mr Speaker I Rise to make a a
motion uh you're recognized to speak
representative Griffin not for a
motion
chair recognizes what do reason does a
member rise Mr Speaker for a motion
State your motion I'd like to make a
motion we table this
bill representative B DeSaro moves
that house bill 1264 be laid on the
table a division has been
requested all m members take your
seats yeah
it's
okay
the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 1264 on the
table this is a division
vote the chair recognizes representative
Barbara Griffin for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the subject of
this bill comes without recommendation
from the committee ensuring long debates
on the issues presented by this
bill and if I know that even if past
this bill would have no impact on
upcoming elections in
2022 and none on local elections in
2023 because of the process that needs
to be followed for a community to opt in
and if I know that this purports to be
enabling legislation but none of the
entities it purports to be enabling
asked for it would I now press the green
button to table this
bill J recognizes representative Craig
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that no party political party
or municipality would be required to opt
into this optional system of rank Choice
voting and if I know that uh the
organizations which have opted in and
successfully used rank Choice voting
include the Republican parties of Utah
Illinois and Virginia and if I know that
supporters political philosophies range
from Progressive to libertarian to very
conservative what I now press the red
button so that debate on this bill may
continue thank
you the motion before us is a tabling
motion on House Bill
1264 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppos you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote Al will attend to the state of the
vote 200 6 voting yay 142 voting nay
hb12 64 is laid on the
table majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill
1326 act relative to permissible
campaign contributions by business
organizations and labor unions having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Joe
Alexander for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass sen Connie Lane for the minority of
the committee chair recognizes
representative
Lane speak against the committee
report
thank you Mr
Speaker this bill creates a Level
Playing Field between uh between unions
and corporations with respect to
political
contributions currently business
organizations can donate to political
campaigns regardless of how that money
is generated within the company I either
in its General treasury or for funds
specifically raised for political
donations but La labor unions are only
limited can only use funds that are
raised specifically for political
donations this bill applies the same
rules for both types of organizations
allowing contributions only from funds
specifically earmarked for political
contributions this bill is the solution
that was proposed by jug mlli in his
1999 opinion when he declared the
Broadband on all corporate cont
contributions
unconstitutional he recommended that
business organizations be limited to
usually using only specifically
segregated funds rather than those from
the company's General Treasurer instead
this body changed the law so that
corporations have no restrictions on
where their campaign cont contributions
come come from creating an unfair
Advantage for corporations over labor
unions it does not adversely affect the
first amendment of business
organizations just as it does not
adversely affect those of labor unions
all the bill does is apply consistent
rules for both types of organizations
please vote against the committee's
report of itl and um I respectfully ask
for a division vote Mr
speaker a division vote has been
requested we are down to our last
speaker members take their seats chair
recognizes representative Sweeney to
speak for the committee report thank you
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker House Bill 1326
upends the process for employers and
granted State businesses to engage in
the political process this body
spearheaded and the governor signed
comprehensive campaign Finance reform
just last year the United States Supreme
courtt court has ruled time and time
again that political contributions to
campaigns or organizations are a form of
free speech protected by the First
Amendment regulating them in the manner
that is proposed in House Bill 1326
would be a stringent and burdensome
overregulation of our first amendment
rights and I urge you all to vote in
favor of our majority and expedient to
legislate motion thank
you motion before us is a majority
report of inexpedient to legisl on House
Bill
1326 this is a division
vote members take your
seats
[Music]
we we we're already in the voting mode
for a
division the motion before us is any
speeding to legislate on House Bill 1326
this is a division
vote this if you're in favor you'll
press the green button
if you're opposed
you chair recognizes representative
Mirad for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that HB
1326 puts unions on a fair and equal
footing with corporations with respect
to political engagement would I press
the red button so a new motion could be
made chair recognize representative
Sweeny for parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
house bill 1326 infringes on the First
Amendment rights of our constituents and
further Mr Speaker if I know that this
body already passed comprehensive
campaign Finance reform just last year
would I now support the majority report
of inexpedient to legislate by pressing
the green button thank you the motion
before us is the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislator and
House Bill 1326 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're Pros you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote
185 voting aay 161 voting nay committee
report is
adopted majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill 1394 an act relative to the
reporting of certain campaign
contributions relative to political
contributions made by limited liability
companies consider the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate pres of Joe Sweeney and the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass sen of Connie Lane
for the minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative of Lane to
speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker this bill
clarifies that individual members of a
limited liability company are subject to
the same political campaign contribution
limits as our individuals such as us and
corporations presently each LLC is
treated separately for the purpose of
direct campaign contributions regardless
of who controls it or who belongs to it
candidates can receive multiple
contributions from separate llc's which
are often created at the same address
and controlled by the same person
Corporation or group of people these
members of the members of the llc's
whether individuals or corporations are
allowed to spend over the statutory
campaign limits set for them by using
this loophole which has become known as
the LLC
loopo this bill would close that making
the existing contribution limits meaning
meaningful because without them they're
meaningless without it individuals and
corporations can form numerous llc's to
get around the
Caps this bill is not in violation of
anyone's First Amendment rights as some
have claimed just as campaign limits for
individuals and corporations are not
violations of their first amendment
rights all this does is close the
loophole available now only to
llc's this bill is a campaign financing
bill that increases transparency and
accountability and the fact that we did
campaign financing last year doesn't
mean we can continue to clean up
campaign financing this year thank you
Mr Speaker and I would ask for a
division
vote representative Barry has asked for
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded we are down to the last speaker
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call call vote members take your
seats chair recognizes representative
Sweeny to speak for the committee report
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker House
Bill 1394 is a bill that simply cannot
and should not work for New Hampshire
this proposed legislation would require
political contributions made by an LLC
to be attributed to the member of the
LLC and counted against their
contribution limit however we don't
track memberships of llc's in the state
of New Hampshire you could have a one
member LLC or a 50 member LLC and no
existing state statute or proposed state
statute by this legislation would report
to the public or to any state agency the
membership of that LLC a contribution
from an LLC is viewed the same as a
contribution from an individual in state
law and in court findings and we should
not upend that process this body
considered nearly identical legislation
last year and we found it inexpedient to
legislate then and we should find it
inex expedient to legislate today thank
you the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1394 this is a
roll call vote members take your
seats
the chair recognizes representative
Mirad for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I knew
that this bill shines a light on dark
money in
politics would I vote against the itl by
pressing the red button so that a new
motion could be made thank you
chair recognizes representative Barry
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this bill would have
unintended consequences and result in
not only campaign Finance issues but
also reporting issues with the Secretary
of State via the quick system what I now
press the green button to Oppo uh to
support the itl
motion the motion before us is a
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisl and House Bill 1394 this a
roll call vote if you're in favor you
press the green button if you oppos you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
represent
representen represent
Cohen representative
Cohen thank
you
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the
vote 187 voting yay 163 voting nay
committee report is
adopted so the next two are
Division I next to Bill bills are just
divisions and parliamentary inquiries so
don't go wandering off too
far majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill 1442 FN act relative to access to
election and voter information having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen Ross
Berry for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same we enable agree with
the majority Report with the
recommendation that the Bill be referred
for interim study s of Connie Lane for
the minority of the
committee a division has been requested
this will be a division vote members
take your
seats chair
recognizes
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexp to legislator in House
Bill 1442 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Hamlet for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the population of New
Hampshire is becoming more
diverse and if I know that our voting
instructions and ballots may be above
the reading level that is required for
the citizenship test and if I know that
with more research and revisions this
bill could be improved would I then
press the red button to defeat this
motion so another motion could be made
thank you J recogniz representative
Haywood for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that hb1
1442 FN the federal standard from
five lowers the federal standard from 5%
to 3% without any rationale or
population data to support a stricter
New Hampshire standard which even at 3%
does not apply anywhere where in the
state and Mr Speaker if I know that this
requirement especially the third
language could be inordinately expensive
and in some cases a legally defensible
translation may not be possible and
finally Mr Speaker if at some Future
Point the New Hampshire population
demographics do change
sufficiently to Warrant a multilanguage
ballot we should start with a blank
sheet of paper
not HB
1442 Mr Speaker I would press the green
button thank
you motion before us a majority report
of inex to legislator and House Bill
1442 this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppos
press the red button voting stations are
open 30
seconds
representative
s
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 195 voting aay 156 voting nay
committee report is
adopted
this again is a division vote with just
parliamentary inquiries so members will
stay in their
seats majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill 1567 FN act relative to the removal
of election officials from office if and
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senor Barbara
Griffin for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolv
that is inexpedient to legislate pres
Paul berser on for the minority of the
committee the amendment is 101 14h pron
in house record 10A pages 78- 79 the
question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose
nay you eyes have it in the amendment is
adopted the question before us is the
majority report V to pass as
amended this is a division vote the
chair recognizes representative berson
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill is amended would find
municipalities whose election officials
negligently failed to perform their
duties and if I know that negligence is
a concept that is not defined in state
law and if I know that the bill lacks
clarity as to who can file a complaint
relative to negligence whom it should be
filed with and how that complaint is to
be investigated would I then press the
the red no button so that a subsequent
motion may be
made J I recognize the represent quy for
a parliamentary
inqu thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that local
election officials must perform their
election related duties properly to
ensure the Integrity of our
elections and if I know there have been
recent well-documented New Hampshire
instances of substantial
negligence by local election officials
and furthermore Mr Speaker if I know
that assessing significant fines against
municipalities who election whose
election officials have been negligent
would help incentiv incentivize those
municipalities to ensure their elections
are conducted in accordance with the law
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
this legislation would also help
Preserve public confidence in the
Integrity of our
elections would I then vote Yes to the
ought to pass motion for this bill by
pressing the green button thank
you motion before us is the majority
committee report of a pass as amended on
House Bill
1567 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative Val
have Meb
up representative
n thank
you
all members present have an opportunity
to
vote also attend the state of the
vote 187 voting yay 165 voting nay
committee reports
adopted majority on the committee on
environment and agriculture to which was
referred House Bill 1454 FN an act
relative to permits for the sitting of
new
landfills having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation Bill
ought to pass with Amendment
representative Megan Murray for the
majority of the
committee majority the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with a majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
sen Barbara ktoa for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0894 printed in house record 10A page 61
are you ready for the vote on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the question
before us is ought to pass on with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay
the eyes have it and the commit report
is
adopted
the house will be in
order
the house will be an
order the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which was referred House Bill 1065 FN an
act relative to the regulation of art
therapists having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Matthew sanon aaso for the majority of
the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following amendment in
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
William Marsh for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise for a motion State your motion I'd
like to put House Bill 1065 on the
table representative Maguire moves to L
House Bill 1065 on the table divisions
been requested this will be a division
vote members take your
seats
now will come to order the question is
WEA to lay House Bill 1065 on the table
representative Marsh is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that New
Hampshire currently has a desperate
shortage of mental health practitioners
and patients are suffering as a result
and if I know that in 14 states in the
district of Colombia art therapists have
been allowed to have licenses to
practice in this
capacity and if I believe granting such
licenses now would reduce the current
burden on our substantially overburdened
Mental Health Care practitioners would I
then press the red button so that we can
allow the debate on this issue thank
you as a reminder we're in the voting
mode members should be in their seats
please representative Maguire is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that art
therapists are regulated by the state
and quite a few of them do in fact
practice in New Hampshire and if I know
that they appear to be very happy with
this regulation because none of them
came and bothered the DNA committee
would I not press the green button to
table House Bill
1065 the question is whether a house
bill 1065 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
be pressing the green button if you're
opposed press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
representative vinc
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 180 having voted in the affirmative
150 in the negative House Bill 1065 is
laid on the
table got
it the majority the committee on
executive departments and administration
which was referred House Bill 1135 an
act requiring a performance audit of the
department of education education
Freedom account program having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Tony
Lakers for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
in expedient to legislate representative
Sally fellow for the minority of the
committee the committee amendment is
0847 H printed on house record 10 a on
page
15 the member from holderness
representative fellows is recognized to
speak against the committee
amendment I want to begin by saying that
the minority recommend mendation printed
in the calendar is incorrect it should
be ought to pass the full committee
supports an audit of the education
Freedom accounts not one person spoke
against it we just disagree on when the
audit should take place the amendment
delays it by one year this program gives
parents $4,000 to $8,000 per child which
can be spent or it can be kept on
account to be used in future years by
the parents the state will give an
outside contractor more than $8 million
this year and likely $16 million or more
next year it is our responsibility as
state representatives to ensure that
taxpayers money is being handled in
accordance with state laws and sound
financial management practices this is
not a financial audit this is an audit
of management procedures it will look at
such things as how is the income
eligibility determined this can be
complicated for married P unmarried
parents or Blended
Families how is state
residen state residency verified it can
is it being done each year do children
and the parents actually live in New
Hampshire is there address a vacation
home or the home of a
relative does class wallet a web
application parents use to make most of
their purchases favor B certain Vis
businesses or give them access to
protected personal
data the contractor is a not nonprofit
and class wallet is a
subcontractor which entity is holding
the quarterly payments from the State
and where is this money held in a bank
account in stocks in
cryptocurrency since the main focus of
this audit is accountability for State
money and not educational outcomes next
winter is not too soon for an audit
Auditors will be able to review a year
and a half of financial data and two
years of eligibility determinations for
more than three ,000
students as the Director of the audit V
division wrote in his letter to Edna
early all audits quote identify areas
needing immediate attention and give an
opportunity to fix those issues
immediately please vote no on the
amendment so the audit can be published
next year and we can make any needed
legislative changes in in
2024 a division vote was requested on
this and we are at the final speaker the
member from Hudson representative Tony
lakus is recognized to speak and support
of the amendment thank you Mr
Speaker I strongly support auditing the
various departments and programs in the
executive branch having those audits
done reviewing them and then following
up to make sure good recommendations for
change are implemented is an important
part of the job for this
legislature however for an audit to
provide useful information a program has
to have been in place with stable rules
for a minimum of one year and preferably
several years that is the recommendation
the committee received from the director
of the audit division of the legislative
budget assistant the problem is that the
rules for the education Freedom account
program were just approved by the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules and the final rules do differ
significantly
from the interim rules that it started
with also as we have seen there are many
bills before the house that could affect
this program and there are more bills
before the other body if any of those
bills passed they would also affect the
operation of the program if the state
has to spend the resources of the audit
division to do the audit and at the
Department of Education to provide
information for that audit it should be
done in a time frame which will provide
useful
information if done too soon it won
won't be an audit of the actual program
as it operates and would operate into
the future that could result in
inconclusive and inaccurate results from
the audit the amendment to this bill
moves the effective date from July of
this year to July of
2023 doing so will ensure that there is
at least one full school year and fiscal
year of stable operations to the audit
please support this motion uh to adopt
the amendment to produce an effective
audit of the fa program thank
you
the question is whether to adopt
Amendment 0847 H this is a division vote
members please take your
seats
close
enough the question is on whether to
adopt Amendment 0847 H representative
fellows is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I believe we owe it to the
New Hampshire taxpayers to verify that
state money is being handled
appropriately that money is going only
to qualified students and the
contractors are following all state laws
and if I believe we need to know as soon
as possible if there are any problems so
those problems can be corrected as soon
as possible possible will I now press
the red button so this audit will not be
delayed representative Maguire is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that a performance audit is a major
undertaking on the part of the state and
if I know that the Department of
Education is currently undergoing a
performance audit on special education
programs and would find it difficult to
support a second one at the same time
and if I know that the audit division
strongly supports delaying this
performance audit would I not press the
green button to delay it by one
year the question is whether to adopt
Amendment 0847 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
have all members present at an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 187 having voted in the affirmative
148 and the negative the Amendments
adopted the question now is on the
majority committee report of a to pass
as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is is
adopted the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
to which was referred House Bill 1171 FN
an act exempting certain Niche Beauty
services from lure requirements having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment represent Jennifer
rhods from the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jackie Gro for the minority of the
committee
hello for what reason does the member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker let go
ahead I would like to make a motion to
table House Bill
okay the motion is to lay House Bill
1171 on the table are you ready for the
question speak that might be
representative Bert requesting a roll
call and it appears to be sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
you need
a
all right the question is whether to lay
House Bill 1171 on the table this is a
roll call vote representative the house
will come to
order representative Gro is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the house bill
1171 may put the house in conflict with
public perception of Public Safety
through licensing would I vote green to
table this this Bill thank
you representative Osborne's recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that occupational licensing reform is of
critical importance at this point in
time uh and high in the mind of the
public Consciousness would I now press
the red
button the question is whether to lay
House Bill 1171 on the table this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 156 having voted in the affirmative
189 and the negative the motion fails
well hold
up
so uh representative CH 11 we do not
have a vote for you because it appears
you're not sitting in your assigned seat
so we need you to go there
and if you're in the chamber you have to
cast a
vote 156 having voted in the affirmative
190 in the negative the motion
fails
all right so we're still on House Bill
1171 the major the committee amendment
is
0843 H printed in page uh in house
record 10A on page 16 the question is
whether to adopt the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the question now is on the
majority committee report of ought to
pass with Amendment the member from Ry
representative Gro is recognized to
speak against the committee report and
this is a one-on-one so don't go
far thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill
1171 exemp certain beauty treatments
from lure requirements by making it
legal to offer blow
drying makeup application eyelash
extensions that are currently done by
licensed individuals to be performed by
anyone this bill does not require so
much as a course in sanitation infection
prevention or a passage of an exam this
this is out of step with all other
states there are no states that allow
individuals to perform cosmetic or
beauty services without minimum training
or supervision by licensed individuals
some states require a public posting
that those performing these services are
not
licensed this bill does not require this
stipulation in the specific case of
eyelash
extensions a chemical is placed in the
eye area and the minority
is strongly not in favor of this
allowance there are no states that allow
this service without licensing and
training for the purposes of aesthetic
or
cosmetic appearance thank
you the member from Winchester
representative RH is recognized to speak
and support of the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
House Bill 1171 FN will allow a person
to provide certain Beauty services such
as blow dry styling curling or arranging
of a person's
hair or makeup
application some eyebrow services in
last Services as well without having to
have a cosmetology or Aesthetics license
to do so these are services that most
people already do at home or have a
friend or family member do for them
currently New Hampshire is only one of
10 states that is not exempt for some of
these Services while every single
bordering state offers is at Le at least
one of these
exceptions the accepted services will
not include practices that involve hair
the hair coloring chemicals perming
chemicals hair cutting shears raises or
any specialty tools that require
Advanced
Training by the way a person is able to
walk into a store right now and buy at
home hair coloring and her home Cuts I
wouldn't recommend it hate your
hair we heard in committee one of the
reasons not to pass this bill was
because if a person has an allergic
reaction or skin condition a
cosmetologist is trained to recognize
and diagnose that that is illegal a
cosmetologist or estian is not a doctor
nor a dermatologist both being the same
thing they are not allowed to diagnose
or treat any conditions of the scalp or
allergic
reactions an example of someone that may
choose to own operate one of these
establishments is someone that may have
had a cosmetology license at one time
however for any number of reasons does
not
now possibly a person that holds
certification in makeup application
another example is a person that has a
natural-born talent that they have honed
in over the years and decides to open a
business instead of paying for schooling
when their desire isn't to color cut or
perm a person's hair Mr Speaker the
passing of H Bill 1117 FN will promote
entrepreneurship in New Hampshire by
encouraging talented and skilled
individuals to supply work for in demand
services without the need to Tagle
themselves in bureaucratic red tape and
Licensing Laws thank you Mr
Speaker
represent maybe that was backwards but
it was effective representative Barry
request a world call which was
preemptive ly significantly seconded so
this will be a roll call vote members
please take your
seats
e
okay the question is on the majority
committee report of AA pass with
Amendment representative Gro is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that during the committee
hearings eyelash extensions and the glue
that is used to apply individual
eyelashes to to um current to existing
eyelashes were the issue that the
minority had with this Bill and this was
an amendment that was not entertained by
the
committee would I now
vote read on this Bill thank
you representative McGuire is recognized
for parliamentary
inquir thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill removes barriers to entry
for services that are not commonly
provided iny
schools and if I know that nearly all of
them can
be uh performed could be and in fact are
performed at home or by friends without
danger and if I know that that
the ski the skills are not taught in
beauty school so there is no advantage
to requiring lure for this would I not
press the green
button
the questions on the majority committee
report have ought to pass with Amendment
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the r green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 2011 having voted in the
affirmative 147 and the negative the
committee report is
adopted the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
to which was referred House Bill 1173 an
act claiming August 9th as indigenous
people's day having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Tony lakus for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass represent Michael
yakubovich for the minority of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
reports
adopted oh
sure the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
and which was referred to House Bill
13:30 an act relative to the board of
registration of medical technicians
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
Michael yakubovich for the majority of
the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
William Marsh for the minority of the
committee the question is on the
majority
Amendment
0399 H prined in house record 10A on
page 47 the member from Brookfield
representative Marsh has recognized
speak against the
amendment thank you Mr Speaker I rise
today in opposition to the majority
amendment 0399 to House Bill
1330 the majority Amendment repeals the
board of medical technicians and ends
the registration of individuals who work
in medical fields and both have contact
with the public and opportunity to
divert opioid
drugs we would revert to the private
sector to prevent drug diversion and
there is good evidence that that has
been
ineffective this board was established
in 2016 in response to the hepatitis C
outbreak at exitor hospital briefly a
traveling technician in the cardiac
catheterization lab was diverting
fentanyl for personal use refilling drug
vials with saline using dirty needles
and thereby contaminating them with his
own hepatitis
C Public Health tested 174 patients who
had procedures 32 patients were
identified with active hepatitis C
identical to the technicians virus and
27 additional patients had evidence of
past hepatitis C infection but their
virus could not be
tested the individual involved was
eventually sentenced to 39 years in
federal prison for infecting 46 people
in four states with this deadly
disease he told his story to Newsweek
and it was published as the cover story
Confessions of a Night Shift junkie in
June
2015 the US attorney for New Hampshire
described him as a serial
infector Newsweek quoted this technician
as saying somebody has to tell how it's
done how easy it is and how the
structure of the hospitals isn't any
good to stop it he told how he hid his
drug use how he manipulated staffing
agencies to continue to get new hospital
jobs and how he was ultimately caught
when the hepatitis C outbreak occurred
at exitor hospital the last of the 19
hospitals in eight states where he had
worked clearly the private sector was
totally ineffective in protecting the
public as a hospital trustee I know that
I have learned to suspect applications
from people who have moved from
jurisdiction to
jurisdiction and yet despite the
testimony of the New Hampshire Hospital
Association and others the majority
wants us to remove this registration
process that deters serial infectors
from applying for jobs in New
Hampshire New Hampshire was the first
state to require registration of such
technicians and there have been no
similar outbreaks in the state
subsequently just by requiring
registration we deter most of these
people who Skip from state to state one
step ahead of the law from applying to
positions in New Hampshire according to
the association of surgical
technologists as of now 12 states
require certification of surgical
technologists and three more besides New
Hampshire require Reg
registration I urge you all to defeat
this amendment so the minority Amendment
which would continue to protect your
constituents and the public can be
brought forward I thank
you the member from hookit
representative yakubovich is recognized
to speak in support of the committee
Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker
so the registration of medical
technicians is extremely rare in the US
and in the existing structure we're
already talking about layers and layers
of Institutions that oversee and work
with the technicians because technicians
work inside a hospital or inside a
lab um I I I want to we want to pass
this amendment the majority of the
committee because shifting of
responsibility is very dangerous
faceless bureaucracy is not going to
help much when when there are already
layers of people people that are
responsible like the hospital trustees
the Insurance Corporation for the
hospital the hospital administrators the
doctors the nurses the staff should see
who they hire and what they do to
patients they've promised not to do harm
and they and they fall back on the
bureaucracy to protect uh their
business there's a break in the chain of
command and they should be responsible
on what happens to the patients that's
why we're repealing this unnecessary
Neary registration of medical
technicians
um it's holding us back from providing
better Services the health care facili
is already struggling to hire
workers and if we remove this
barrier uh by eliminating registration
in the field we provide better service
to the public so please vote for the
committee Amendment thank
you representative Marsh request a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take your
seats who requested a roll
call who yeah but who requested the roll
call who
did and it is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call
vote
the question is on Amendment
0399 H this is a roll call vote
represent of marsh has recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry Mr
Speaker if I know night shift junkies
have been discouraged from plaguing New
Hampshire by the existing registration
process and if I know both hospitals and
confessed night shift junkies have said
the hospital vetting process is totally
inadequate to protect the public and if
I don't want another massive and
expensive outbreak of disease spread by
the dirty needles of night shift junkies
to affect my friends and neighbors would
I not press the red button and defeat
the majority Amendment thank
you representative Maguire is recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the actions of one bad
actor however heus are not reason to
require thousands of technicians to
register and pay the fees if I know that
these technicians never work
independently but only under the
supervision of doctors and other Med
Health Care
Professionals and if I know that this
creates an unnecessary barrier to health
to supplying employees to our healthare
businesses would I not press the green
button and adopt the
amendment the question is whether to
adopt Amendment 0399 H this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 175 having voted in the affirmative
168 in the negative the amendment is
adopted the bills on second reading and
open a further Amendment representative
Marsh moves Amendment 0699 H printed in
house record 10A on pages 47 through
50 and is recognized speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker and I thank
the house for this opportunity to undo
the Mis the terrible thing we are doing
to the public with the amendment we just
adopted uh this minority Amendment
replaces the bill with a minority bill
um the board has been recently
dysfunctional due to its inability to
obtain quorum to do its duties uh this
uh bill as amended by the minority
Amendment would make it an Advisory
board so that oplc can function and the
minority Amendment ensures that the
advis The Advisory Board is consulted
whenever important decisions need to be
made I urge you to adopt this amendment
thank
you representative Maguire has
recognized speak against the minority
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker I have to
agree with the previous speaker that if
you adopt this amendment you completely
undo what you did in the adopting the
majority Amendment so I would urge you
not to B not to waste everyone's Time by
voting for it thank
you the question is whether to adopt
Amendment 0699 H are you ready for the
question division's been
requested representative n request a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is this will be a roll call vote
members please take your seats
the question is on Amendment 0699 H this
is a roll call
vote the member from Brookfield
representative Marsh is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry waves off
all right let's just do
it if you're in favor of adopting the
amendment you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
167 having voted in the affirmative 184
and the negative the amendment
fails oh dear okay
so now we're on the majority committee
report of AA pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay I
the eyes have it and the committee
reports
adopted the committee on executive
departments Administration which was
referred House Bill
1357 an act relative to land
acknowledgement having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Tony lakus for the committee
the questions on the majority committee
report of in expedient you legislate are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say
I all those oppos nay no the eyes have
it and the committee reports
adopted there were names nobody asked
for
so I have to apologize to the house and
ask you for a
favor I know I didn't see the second
sheet and there are people that were
going to debate the last bill instead I
crank through a Voice vote so I would
like someone to please make a motion to
reconsider the bill and then have
everybody vote Yes so that the people
who signed up did the work to write the
speeches can do
that representative Graham is recognized
for a
motion Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side I ask that we Rec
considerer our actions on the last
bill representative Graham moves
reconsideration on House Bill 1350 7 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppos nay
[Applause]
no I am in doubt that we did the right
thing so let's clarify it with a
division
vote
e
you're right it
is the house will be in
order the question is whether to
reconsider House Bill
1357 representative Mar Smith is
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
sometimes we get tired and we aren't
necessarily paying attention and if I
know that we might have missed the very
serious and important request from the
presiding officer that we
reconsider would I now vote Yes on the
motion to
reconsider representative McGuire's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I I know
that this bill is of purely symbolic
importance would I not press the red
button to not
reconsider we're in the voting mode
representative
inqu real in is it a real
inqu stay your inquiry Mr Speaker my
inquiry would be this I I understand
that you've said that you that you made
a mistake which is completely
understandable my question would be that
if somebody
if before the ISS you had placed the
issue as you had if somebody had said I
don't want to have a debate let's just
go vote would you have allowed them to
do
that all parties would have to agree so
doesn't that suggest to the body that
the request that was was made by the by
the speaker should be granted that we
should allow this to be
redone I I appreciate you back me up the
not a real parliamentary inquiry though
thanks house will be in order the
question is whether to
reconsider House Bill
1357 this is a division
vote voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative griin representative
rard
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 238 having voted in the affirmative
94 and the negative the motion passes
thank
you and I apologize to the house for my
mistake wasting so much of your
time
for what reason does a member rise make
a motion State your motion I'd like to
lay it upon the
table representative Spain moves at
House Bill 1357 be laid on the
table division's been requested this
will be a division
vote members take your
seats
house will come to order the question is
whether to lay House Bill 1357 on the
table representative Spain's recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we still have a lot of
work to do do and I know how this that
we all know how this one turns out would
I go ahead and push the green button and
put it on the
table representative goal is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know we just reconsidered our
earlier vote so that we could hear this
small debate would I now press the red
button so we continue with debate and
get on with the day thank
you the question is whether to L House
Bill 13 1457 on the table this a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for another 30
seconds
well all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 163 in the affirmative 178 and the
negative the motion
fails the house will be in
order I said the house will be in order
we're finally getting to a debate that
was delayed by a lot of
stuff it is one-on one so don't go
far the member from Ry representative
groa is recognized to speak against the
committee
report and has a right to be
heard thank you Mr
Speaker in Edna we hold hearings on
bills
regarding honoring specific events and
causes on first glance house Bill 1537
appears to be such a
bill and as you know the those bills
that come to this house from the Edna
committee often come with an
itl motion because among it is an
agreement among the members of the
committee that there are more productive
options for these
requests House Bill
5357 on land
acknowledgement asks for no
commemoration or
Fanfare and this is not a simple Bill
the subject de deserves much more than a
quick look House Bill 1357 recognizes
that before there was New Hampshire
there was a land called
andak and that the abanaki Penacook and
wanaki peoples a confederation of Indian
tribes were a distinct people in New
Hampshire this land had the same
mountains rivers streams and forests
that we all hold precious today this
land remains magical and loved by us all
this land is a Continuum inhabited by
many people and its history is
important regardless of who lived here
or who lives here today the natural
beauty of our state remains and is and
is protected and is protected and is why
many of us are here in this house I ask
you to join me in overturning the itl
motion by voting red so that another
motion is made thank
you the member from Hudson
representative Tony Lakers is recognized
to speak for the committee
report
oh thank
you thank you Mr Speaker
um so this bill would amend RSA 1
concerning the boundaries of the State
of New Hampshire to acknowledge that
there were people here before us which
is uh not
disputable
um and while we're sure the sponsors of
the bill intended it just be a
respectful acknowledgement of the
peoples who are here before us and to
keep the people in New Hampshire aware
of that history there is concern about
how that acknowledgement might be
construed in the future while we
understand the sponsors and most of the
supporters do not intend this
acknowledgement to support possible land
claims we must always be aware of
possible unintended consequences of
legislation the statute created by the
current legislation will likely persist
for many years I mean it's RSA 1 which
defines the boundaries of this
state and uh even uh during our uh
committee hearing we had at least one
person who testified and and uh talked
about restorative justice in the context
of this bill which was
concerning and uh the other thing is we
got uh testimony from a tribal
genealogist who said that uh there's
conflict between groups of the
indigenous people in New York and Canada
over how this should be handled and uh
this person said it' be best for the
State of New Hampshire not to meddle in
that situation so because of all that uh
those reasons I ask you to vote um green
to support the itl motion thank
you the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1357 division votes been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats
now will come to
order and members please find your seats
probably right where you left
them the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1357 the member from Ry representative
Gro is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that history is important and
that the Luxy of our the Continuum of
our land is also important and if I know
that there is an amendment that was
passed by the committee that would
refute any land claims that this
acknowledgement
would that this acknowledge would not
recognize would I now vote green no vot
vote red to overturn I'm so sorry I'm to
vote red on overt turny itl motion thank
you that's why we
ask the member from Hudson
representative Tony Lakers is recognized
for parliamentary in
quiry or representative Maguire's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this purely symbolic Bill merely
recognizes one group of indigenous
peoples and if I also know that the
other groups of indigenous peoples in
the state are not pleased with it would
I not press the green button to keep us
out of the out of that their fights
thank
you
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1357 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you
will press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
183 having voted in the affirmative 151
in a negative the committee report is
adopted the committee on executive
departments at Administration to which
is refer at House Bill 1510 an act
establishing a committee to study the
hiring processes used by state agencies
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Matthew sasto
for the committee the question is on the
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos
nay the eyes have it and the committee
reports
adopted the committee on executive
departments Administration to which was
referred House Bill 1560 an act relative
to non-resident Lure by the Board of
barbering cosmetology and Aesthetics
having consider the same report the same
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Jennifer
rhs for the committee the questions on
the majority committee report of ought
to pass are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
reports
adopted
thank I heard a little bit of what
happened 20 minutes
to the house will be in
order majority the committee on finance
to which was referred House Bill 103 FN
act establishing a dental benefit under
the State Medicaid Program having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation ation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment of Jess Edwards
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and unable to agree
with the majority report the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate Bob Lyn for the minority of
the
committee the amendment is
0904 printed in house record 10A Pages 2
to 4 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those opposed n
no the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted question before the
house is the ought to pass with
Amendment motion are you ready for the
question roll call has been requested by
representative Pratt is that
sufficiently seconded is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
house will be in
order the motion before us
is house will be in
order the motion before us is ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 103 FN
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recogniz to representative wer for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that HB 103 passed the house
on a roll call vote of 225 to
127 and pass the finance committee on a
vote of 14 to5 and if I further know
that this program will be financed by a
lawsuit settlement of $18 million so it
will be not not added to our taxes then
would I now push the green button in
hopes that our Medicaid population will
have improved Health thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass as
with Amendment on House Bill 103 FN it's
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
appros you press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
of the
vote 237 voting yay 100 voting nay
committee report is
adopted
we have the committe
am
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 1677 FN an act
relative to the administration and the
settlement of claims of abuse at the
Youth Development Center and making an
appropriation therefore considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment Carin
umberger forther
committee Amendment
0956 H printed in house record 10A Pages
85 through
90 the question is on the commit the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay committee Amendment are
adopted bill is on second reading open
to further Amendment representative
Rogers and walner offer Amendment
138h printed in house record 10A Pages
90 through
91 chair Rec
recognizes representative long to speak
to the
amendment thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker i' first like to commend the
collaborative work with the attorney
general the victims attorney and
especially the finance committee uh I I
was quite impressed on the collaborative
work that they had done uh towards this
this bill uh this amendment adds
emotional abuse I I believe New
Hampshire has an opportunity in address
an all victimization done
at the hands of our facilities
especially at minimum through House Bill
1677 process all victims retain their
right to choose the court process
however this process ought to be
available to all victims who choose so
uh although the appropriation is an
extremely large
allocation I'm reminded of the tax
dollars that went towards perpetration
of of these acts so I ask that you
support the victims
the victims of in in this situation and
we add all victims the opportunity to go
through this process uh thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognizes the represent
of
Edwards uh thank you Mr Speaker I I'd
like you to understand just a little bit
of the process that gotd us here the uh
for the first time in decades the state
of New Hampshire has stood up to the
plate and said we are responsible and we
are going to be accountable for writing
the wrongs of many many decades where
kids that have been incarcerated in the
Youth Development Centers uh have been
warehoused to in a way in which um
physical and sexual abuse seems to have
been fairly current uh common and and
too much of a part of the culture that's
what I'm hearing anecdotally don't admit
that into court but that's what I
understand and so what the AG has done
is uh he and his office have set up a
settlement fund so that we can
efficiently process hundreds of
claims and the key claims that we must
address are the sexual and physical
abuse like any project this is a this is
a new project
the biggest thing you need to worry
about is scope creep if you make the
scope too big your Project's going to
fail and so with a lot of thought we and
and debate we are not we don't want the
emotional abuse included in this bill
which is what this amendment does
because first of all emotional abuse is
very tough I think to to adjudicate I
think just the mere fact that you're
incarcerated
would uh legitimately would would would
many feel like emotional abuse and
because it's it's it's messy and it
would open up uh the settlement fund to
a a scope creep that is beyond what
we're ready to do initially and we may
never get to that but don't think for a
moment that those kids who thought that
they were emotionally abused don't have
recourse there's always been a method
for them to file a complaint with the AG
and to have it adjudicated and that's
that Avenue remains open to them what
we've done is we've set up a settlement
fund to efficiently process a large
large number of cases and I'd ask you to
vote against this amendment so that we
can allow the Attorney General to focus
on the most egregious claims and and get
them handled as expeditiously as
possible thank you some member yield the
questions I
I I I uh I repres I um I respect the
representative I'll take her question
member May inquire thank you so much
[Music]
representative thank you so much
representative for taking my question
are you saying that um watching a child
get raped by uh a facilit that
facilitates this is is less important
and and should get less rewards of
Damages than the one that's actually
doing the raping and is getting
threatened to then be raped if they tell
anybody so so I thank you for the
question and I I understand your concern
to be whether or not uh rape would be
included I'd say rape is part of the
sexual assault and that and that's
clearly the major reason we're doing
this is to um uh adjudicate and and pay
out and try to uh compensate for their
pain and anguish uh the the monies that
would help them deal with the the rape
so hopefully that answers your question
and I I think we're done does the member
yield to further questions no no member
does not
yield a division has been requested
members take your
seats
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment
1038 l
h this is going to be a division
vote chair recognizes representative
walner for for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this amendment
will strengthen this very very important
bill and if I know that this amendment
will add emotional abuse in the
definition of child abuse and if I know
that research shows
that emotional abuse and solitary
confinement can cause lifelong damage to
young children and young
adults and if I know for this settlement
process to work the process must be
viewed as
inclusive and open to all
claimants would I now vote Yes to this
amendment you Rec representative
umberger for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that emotional abuse
child
endangerment false imprisonment unlawful
confinement child exploitation or
deprivation of Education
rights are issues that should be
considered but should not be added to
the definition of sexual abuse or
physical abuse would I now press the red
button and vote no on this amendment
thank
you the motion before us is floor
Amendment 1038
H it is is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're propos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Griffith
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to state to the
vote 164 voting yay 177 voting nay floor
Amendment
fails the hous is the bill is on second
reading open to further
Amendment this is floor Amendment
H the chair recognizes
representative Rogers to speak to the
floor
[Music]
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker um I want
to start out first of all by in telling
you that in the spirit of bip
partisanship with the member will
suspend for a minute until we get the
sound
on thank you Mr
Speaker and first of all in the spirit
of bipartisanship with which this bill
was written um I have to thank the
member from londondary for the hat that
I'm wearing today which is the US Marine
Corps hat so I'm sure you can all tell
which member from londondary and I hope
that in light of that he'll listen to
what I say and vote with me um house B
1677 is amended is a great
start okay but we can act now to make it
an even more effective response to a
critical situation Amendment 1022 H will
help to do that according to the
Department of Children and Family
Services director from 1990 to the
present
4,776 children were housed at this new
new youth center and its predic cessor
they've already there have already been
close to 500 cases of abuse filed in the
courts and that number could increase as
a former County attorney this situation
resonates with me it's clear based on
the number of cases filed against the
state that the financial cap on
settlements in this bill is artificially
low at 1.5 million it should be
increased to 4.5 million this is a
significant increase but there's there's
a cause to do this from a legal
standpoint the state by taking complete
custody and control of these children
had a fiduciary duty to them we promised
to provide the highest standard of
care if this case goes to civil court
all the plaintiffs have to prove by a
preponderance of the evidence which is
50.1% likelihood is that the abuse
happened as lawmakers we must be
prepared to respond to several judges
ments against the state of New Hampshire
keep in mind the state has already
indicted 12 former employees and
Promises to indict more these employees
account for the abuse of close to one
half of the child victims and the state
believes it can prove the defendants
abuse these kids Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt a 98%
likelihood for our purposes this means
these cases will either be settled and
receive a financial award from this fund
that we are creating or the cases go to
trial the plaintiffs have several
lawyers already committed to working
these cases on behalf of the child
victims so far the attorney general has
one it's entirely possible that if any
of these cases or several of these cases
go to trial that when jurors hear what
happened to these children multi-million
dollar verdicts in single cases will
result
it's critical to note some of the cases
in federal court in recent years
exceeded $20 million even for incidences
less brutal than child rape the federal
court draws from a similar jury pool as
our state Superior Court in miramac
County where these cases would be heard
you have to anticipate the same jury
pool will yield similar
outcomes it's in the state's best
financial interest to agree to a process
that will resolve all or almost all of
these child victim cases as
expeditiously as possible with as little
additional trauma to the victims as
possible after all it's the right thing
to do Amendment 1022 expands the cap on
settlements to 4.5 million a more
realistic cap on settlement amounts if
we want the plaintiffs to come to the
table with their claims and avoid going
to civil court where $10 million or
higher dollar claims could result
we must be realistic about the logical
and likely Financial risks we should
increase the cap the state is willing to
award in this process I ask that you
join me in more properly compensating
any victims of abuse while in the
state's custody please support Amendment
1022 by voting yes and pressing the
green button thank you Mr
Speaker chair recogniz the
representative
hurger
thank you Mr
Speaker
sorry the cap in 10
1677 is $1.5 million for sexual abuse
and
$150,000 for fiscal
abuse these C apps were set as a result
of the AG looking out across the country
for what settlements were out there
for uh sexual abuse and physical
abuse and that was the number that
the the dollars that the AG came to us
with as what was the I don't want to
call it the average settlement because
it wasn't necessarily adding up the
figures and coming up with a number it
was looking at all of the cases that
were out
there
now as uh the representative from
conquer said you don't have to choose
the process that we've put together in
1677 is designed as
a trauma and victim
centered process as opposed to going to
court which is not
necessarily a victim or
trauma centered thing but this the cap
that we have put in the bill I believe
will actually solve all of the problems
that were caused and I would agree that
these are absolutely horrible to think
that this was going on in our youth
centers over a long period of time and
it was only recently that the AG in his
um work discovered the horrific nature
of what was going on so I ask that you
vote red and keep the Caps that are
currently in
1677 of 1.5 million for sexual abuse and
150,000 for fiscal abuse thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before
us is on floor Amendment
1036 this is going to be a division vote
members take your seat
need
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1036 H this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative walner for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment will also strengthen this very
important bill and if I know the intent
of this legislation is to provide an
alternative for claimants to settle
their cases through the settlement fund
process as opposed to taking cases to
court which is a must much more
costly set process for the state and for
the victim and if I know that the cap on
settlement is too if it is too low
claimants will choose Court over going
through the settlement fund process and
if I know this amendment raises the cap
to a more realistic level which will
encourage claimants to use the
settlement process would I now vote Yes
on this
amendment chair recognizes
representative Wilder for parliamentary
in inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the attorney general made a
thorough study of rewards for sexual
abuse attacks on children by authorities
and that study led to a proposal to
create a settlement fund of $100 million
to use in a new system to avoid going to
court if the damaged parties accepted it
and if I further know that the attorney
for the approximate 500 litigants kept
trying to increase the caps on the
settlements offered and if I know that
increasing the Caps or the allowed
damages will make even that huge sum be
insufficient would I now press the red
button to keep from making this effort
unworkable thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
floor Amendment 1036 H this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppos OS
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
W speaker
if all members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to the state of
the
vote 165 voting a 184 voting a the
amendment
fails we're back to the original
bill with the committee
Amendment so the motion before us is
ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay no the eyes have it and the
committee report is
adopted the house
will
I'm all the way in the back I'm sorry
I'm running do the I'm doing the best I
can I get it representative you are you
making a motion yes please what is your
motion I'd like for the previous debate
to be printed would you I'd like for the
previous debate to be printed in the
permanent journal without objection the
motion is to replate replace the debate
in the permanent Journal is that it yes
thank
you all those in favor of placing the
debate in the permanent Journal say I
those oppos
nay only those in the room are allowed
to vote a division has been
requested members take your seats there
is no
piis
e
house will come to order the motion
before us is to print the remarks in the
permanent
Journal if you're in favor you will
press the green button if you're opposed
you will press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to the state of
the
vote 188 voting a 155 voting a marks
will be printed in the permanent
Journal majority of the committee on
Fish and Game and Marine Resources to
which was referred house bill
1091 act relative to search warrants for
individuals engaged in fishing game
activities considered the same report
the same the recommended that the bill
be referred for interim study an tendy
lying for the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following resolution resolved as
inexpedient to legislator Mr Larry llam
for the minority of committee the
question motion before us is the
committee report of interim study are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay no the
eyes have it committee report is
adopted before we go on to the next bill
I just want to let everybody know what
the plan is the food will be delivered
about 5:30 it should be all set up and
ready to go for 6:00 so we'll take a
break at 6:00 for hopefully about 45
minutes we're asking you to go down to
the cafeteria that's where it'll be set
up again and then come back here as soon
as possible so that we can hopefully get
another couple hours
in majority of the committee on fishing
game and Marine Resources to which was
referred House Bill 1297 act relative to
taking Lobster while engaged in
recreational scuba diving get considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment James Blain for the minority
of the committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen Katherine Harvey for the
minority of the
committee the amendment is
0157 printed in house record 10A Pages
46- 47 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay no eyes have it and
amendment is
adopted the question before the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill
297 I division has been requested
members take your
seats
the you're doing
it
the house will come to order members be
in your seats this is a division
vote the motion before us is the
majority report of Auto passes amended
on House Bill
1297 this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative AER for a
parliamentary
inquiry Egan my mistake representative
Egan from Sugar Hill Mr Speaker that's
okay it's a long day thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
best way to protect New Hampshire's
precious Lobster stock especially female
egg bearing lobsters and support
economically important lobstering
industry in New Hampshire is the only
way by highly using High highly
professional career seasoned and easily
regulated lobstermen to catch these
valuable creatures and if I believe that
personal hand catching of lobsters by
individual scuba divers with limited
experience will complicate the
monitoring and regulation process of the
already overburdened Marine Patrol
officers of our dear fish and game
department and furthermore if I believe
that the safety of divers will be
diminished as their ability to hand
catch lobsters will most likely take
place where Lobster stocks reside
therefore creating risk to divers
entangling themselves in the Nets trap
lines and other dangerous gear that our
Lobster industry uses would I now vote
no on House Bill 1297 so the better
motion could be made thank you Mr
Speaker J recognizes representative Reed
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
state directly to our South does allow
scuba and free divers to harvest small
amounts of lobster for personal use and
they have had zero issues with
enforcement zero issues with safety and
zero issues with conflicts between
divers and lobstermen and if I know that
none of the usual Pro conservation
pro-animal groups opposed this bill at
all but in fact the main opposition in
committee was a long line of people
representing the professional Lobster
industry who stand to lose the high
dollar Demand on their product if
individuals have access to sustainably
harvesting small amounts for personal
use as they do with fish and if I know
that one of the most preeminent Wildlife
biologists in the state who almost
always is in committee supporting
databased restrictions on take was
passionately supportive of this bill and
in fact debunked the myths that divers
uh cause damage when harvesting uh
sustainable amounts would I now press
green and support the committee
recommendation the motion before us is
is the majority report of autopass as
amended on House Bill
1297 members need to be in their seats
this is a division
vote
the motion before us is the majority
Port of a to passes amended on in House
Bill 1297 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
representative
for
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
of the
vote 197 voting yay 143 voting a
committee report is
adopted
the house will be in
order majority of the committee on
fishing game and Marine sourc to which
was referred House Bill
1356 act relative to the taken of gray
squirrels having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment sen of
Timothy Lang from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the sa being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sen of Ellen Reed from the minority
of the
committee what reason does a member rise
for a Motion state motion I move to
table it is a proper motion the motion
before us is to
table House Bill
1356 are you ready for the
question who requested a roll
call we have a we have a request for a
Division I heard it will this will be a
division vote members take your seats
this is a division
vote
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1356 this is a division
vote the chair recognizes representative
Andrew Balden for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that I sponsored this bill
would I now push green to late on the
table
the chair recognizes representative Lang
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know the
committee listened to two and a half
hours of conversation and public debate
about lactating gray squirrels and
further Mr Speaker if I know that the
amendment was adopted with bipartisan
support and the underlying bill was
ultimately adopted with bipartisan
support would I now vote read to the
tabling
motion motion before us is a table House
Bill
1356 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the
vote
156 voting yay 182 voting nay the motion
to table
fails all right we're going right into a
division vote so members stay in your
seats we're going to be doing just piis
on the amendment the amendment is
0166 H printed in houseal record 10A
page 53 this is going going to be a
division
vote the chair
recognizes representative llam for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that RSA
207 colon
56 requires that the executive director
of the New Hampshire fishing game
department after consultation with the
new Hampshire fishing Game Commission
through their rulemaking Authority shall
have the authority to open and close
seasons for all small game including
gray
squirrels and Mr Speaker if I know that
open and Clos hunting seasons for
garious for various game species are
managed after
consideration on the advice of research
of wildlife
biologist and Mr Speaker if I know that
this amendment requires the executive
director to permit gray squirrels to be
hunted year round rather than during an
open or a closed season like other
species of small game and finally Mr
Speaker if I believe that New Hampshire
wildlife should be managed through the
advice of wildlife
biologists rather than the whim of
legislators then would I push the red
button and vote no on this amendment so
another motion could be brought to the
floor do you recognize representative
lying for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that I listened to two and a
half hours of testimony about lactating
Ray squirrels and Mr Speaker if I know
that after hearing all of that
conversation with both the en Hampshire
Farm Bureau with the forestry division
with the fishing game and many citizens
have testified that I came away with a
completely different opinion as well the
majority of my committee that these
animals have have uh they are the only
rad in to uh have a season other than a
beaver and Mr Speaker would I now vote
to allow an Open Season and the
amendment to go forward on gray
squirrels and push the green button the
motion before us is the ought to pass as
amended motion on House Bill one
majority Amendment the majority
Amendment on House Bill
1356 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Fargo
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to stay to the
vote 194 voting yay 147 voting nay
committee amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is the
majority committee report of ought to
pass as amended on houseal Bill
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those opposed
nay you eyes have it committee report is
adopted right
sir have one onone
with
the house will be in order members take
your seats we have a one-on-one debate
with a request for a roll
call majority of committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 1022 an
act permitting pharmacists to dispense
the drug Ivy mecon by means of a
standing order having considered the
house will come to
order
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment is Leia questionman
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution that is inexpedient
to legislate pres of Gary Merchant for
the minority of the
committee the
amendment is
zero
it's the amendment is
0964 H printed in house record 10A Pages
five and six are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay no the
eyes have it and amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative kerk
to speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker
permitting a pharmacist to dispense a
medication by a standing order requires
a a well- evaluated protocol established
through a broad consensus of providers
and pharmacists using the best available
data but a broad consensus supporting
the use of ivermectin in covid-19 does
not exist the majority report claims
that icin has been shown to be helpful
in reducing the severity and duration of
covid-19 but this is not true there have
been numerous studies regarding icin and
covid-19 which sound compelling but upon
analysis have design flaws I have
personally reviewed many of these
studies most studies so far are limited
by primarily by non-blinding or no
randomization but also by twoo small
sample sizes the use of concominant
medications that confound the assessment
or poorly defined study groups and
outcome measures and even the
well-designed studies still have
significant limitations such that
definitive conclusions regarding the
clinical efficacy of ican and the
treatment of covid-19 cannot yet be
reached this is not an issue of
censorship it is simply subjecting these
studies to the same robust analysis
which must be given to any study
internationally recognized independent
groups with Decades of experience
analyzing studies such as the
group have determined that the few
studies of high quality which do exist
do not support support the use of
ivermectin for treatment or prevention
of covid-19 except in ongoing
well-designed clinical
trials this is not to say that icin is
not a good drug it is excellent for the
treatment of parasitic worms and has
been around for a long time and used
well for that purpose the minority
already worked with the majority to
allow off Lael use of ivermectin so that
it can be obtained if desired standing
orders with pharmacists should should
not be used to dispense medications for
indications which are not clearly
supported by the best available medical
evidence Ivory mechon unfortunately at
least as of now does not yet Reach This
level of evidence so please press the
red button to vote no so that another
motion can be brought forth thank you Mr
Speaker a roll call has been requested
yes
the final speaker is coming up a roll
call has been requested by
representative blazic is that
sufficiently
seconded it is officially seconded this
is going to be a roll call vote members
take your
seats the chair recognizes
representative
kushman thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
this bill as amended would ensure
granite stators have access to an FDA
approved medication that has a drug
safety PR profile better than Tylenol a
standing order is a prescriptive
protocol written by a physician or nurse
practitioner that allows a pharmacist to
dispense a medication without an
individual prescription the prescriber
writes a protocol that includes dosage
and screening for contraindication the
patient receives an information sheet
that informs them of adverse effects
indications and referral information
currently in New Hampshire one can go to
a pharmacy and ask for hormonal
contraceptives and Naran via a standing
order these drugs both carry
substantially more risk than ican icin
has been used in humans for parasitic
infections for over 30 years its success
as an
antiviral uh effective in reducing
severity of symptoms of covid-19 and
other viral illnesses is one reason
people are willing to go to Great
Lengths to obtain it from purchasing a
broad to purchasing ior and formulated
for animals people will do what they
need to do to get their hands on this
drug when they or their loved ones are
sick they'll do what they have to
another reason is that unfortunately
medicine is becoming increasingly
politicized this is why there is
no um consensus on the best protocol for
Icon but we do have many wellestablished
protocols that Physicians who write
these standing orders can reference and
use
because of this politicization doctors
are afraid to prescribe and pharmacies
are afraid to
dispense if we pass this bill patients
will have access to this safe
inexpensive generic FDA approved
medication that is created in FDA
regulated and inspected facilities
formulated for
humans this will reduce the potential
harm of obtaining medications abroad and
using icin formulated for animals and
could potentially mitigate the severity
of covid-19 and other viral illnesses we
make experimental vaccines that have had
no long-term safety studies with growing
evidence of harm available at pharmacies
without a prescription and claim it's
because it could save lives Iver mechon
has had over 30 years of study showing
that it is safe and more and more
evidence is surfacing that it is
effective permitting it to be dispensed
via a standing order could save lives
please vote a to pass as amended thank
you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority report of a to pass as
amended this is going to be a roll call
vote members take your
seats
the motion before us is the majority
report of aut to pass as amended on
House Bill
1022 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative kerk for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that permitting a pharmacist to dispense
a medication by a standing order
requires a well- evaluated protocol
established through a broad consensus of
providers and pharmacists using the best
available data and that the lack of that
consensus is not a political issue but
because of data which is insufficient in
the studies and that only a few have are
actually being done at this point a few
standing orders and if I know that the
FDA FDA approval is for its indication
of treating parasites not
covid-19 and if I know that a broad
consensus supporting the use of icin in
covid-19 does not exist and that
Ivermectin can be obtained off label
once we've finished getting that other
Bill through would I then press the red
button to vote no so that another motion
could be brought forward thank you Mr
Speaker do you recognize the remant mark
Pearson for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that Ivor meon is already
available over the counter in many
countries and if I know that Ivor mechon
is safe safer than some of the
over-the-counter medicines we can
presently buy here in New Hampshire and
if I know that some people unable to get
Ivor mechon over the counter here have
been resorting to going to farm stores
and getting it as it is formulated for
livestock and not for people and finally
if I know that the choice for ever so
many people is not the choice of ior
mecon or
vaccines but ior meon versus
nothing and while it might not cure you
it's not going to hurt you would I now
press the green button to give New
Hampshire people this Freedom of Choice
thank you Mr speak
speaker the motion before us is the
majority report of autop passes amended
on House Bill
1022 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
cordelli
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 180 house will be in order 183
voting yay 159 voting nay the committee
report is
adopted
I request members stay in your seats we
have another request for a roll call on
this coming Bill majority committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which was referred House Bill
1044 an act relative to policies
required for health facilities and
special Health Care Service licenses
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legisl
pres of Jerry kerk for the majority of
the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment s Jim kall from
the minority of the
committee the chair recognizes
representative
kall thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of House Bill 1044 and in
opposition to the committee
recommendation of
itl House Bill
1044 would make a small but meaningful
change in our state statute governing
The Lure of healthc care
facilities in 2016 this legislature
added a provision to that statute
requiring that licensed Health Care
Facilities must serve all patients
regard regardless of the source of
payment House Bill 1044 would exempt
certain facilities from that
provision specifically it would exempt
organizations that operate on a
membership based business model or a
direct payment business model meaning
that it's not reimbursed by
Insurance the key concern raised in the
majority committee
report is that this bill would have an
adverse effect on our critical care
hospitals in fact the provisions in
question were added to Statute in
2016 we had critical care hospitals
before that and if this bill passes
there's no reason to believe we will not
have critical care hospitals after
that furthermore critical care hospitals
are already protected by a 15-m
exclusion
Zone preventing the open opening of
new facilities within that
radius they also receive favorable
Medicare and Medicaid reimbursement
rates based on their uh their status as
critical care
hospitals
protectionism never leads to
efficiency it never leads to cost
savings
and it never Spurs
Innovation free markets
do many of you may be old enough to
remember when making a longdistance
phone call was a little bit expensive
talking to family members in other
states often involved keeping one eye on
the clock making sure you weren't
talking too
long deregulation did wonders for the
Telecommunications
industry it led to better service lower
prices more options for
consumers and more
Innovation widespread use of Technology
embracing new technologies
faster free market Innovation should be
allowed to flourish in New
Hampshire this bill would open a modest
window of opportunity that will lead to
better Services Lower costs and
innovation in our health care System I
ask you to please join me in opposing
the committee recommendation so that an
alternate motion can be brought thank
you thank you Mr
Speaker representative blazic has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded we're down to our
final speaker it is sufficiently
seconded this is going to be a roll call
vote members take your
seats the chair recognizes
representative kerk thank you Mr
Speaker yes currently licensed healthc
care facilities are required to provide
services to all persons regardless of
the source of payment and that
requirement was added in 2016 by the
legislature to ensure access to services
for low-income individuals and those
covered by
Medicaid HB 1044 would exempt Healthcare
facilities which exclusively provide
services on a basis of direct payment
from
this uh from this uh requirement and
that's without any reimbursement from a
third party or any insurance and so it
actually it's been build as something to
help you with your high deductible but
it really won't because that bill has to
be sent through the insurance company in
order to be credited to your
deductible now such a change would allow
a small number of for-profit
Institutions offering Urgent Care
birthing Services Ambulatory Surgery or
other services to skim off the high
paying patients who can pay the full
cash price and that changes the payer
mix for remaining hospitals and that 15
Mile exclusion doesn't make much a
difference I live 15 miles from any
healthc Care
Facility maintaining the payer mix is
important for those remaining hospitals
our critical access hospitals run on
razor thin margins and they lose money
on services such as the full service
24hour per day emergency room and
obstetrical services which serve many
people on Medicaid or with no
insurance those Services which are
critical to have in rural areas are
subsidized by the higher paying services
and the higher paying insurances
skimming off the higher paying patients
would have a significant negative
economic effect on our critical access
hospitals there will be a substantial
risk of Hospital closure or the need to
drop CR clinical critical Clinical
Services such as maternity and we've
seen that happen leaving large numbers
of individuals especially in rural areas
with no access for timely medical care
for emergencies or for child
birth and the losses sustained by those
facilities will be shifted to those who
have insurance driving up the cost for
everyone else and not changing that
total health care
costs the hospitals recognize the threat
of this build to the existence of our
hospitals and the need of all the
hospitals to share the burdens equally
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
testified against this bill stating that
it will not benefit patients access nor
will it improve
competition the majority believes that
this bill will decrease access to health
care and will not drive down the overall
cost of Health
Care I also find it interesting that the
minority has said that this helps the
free market but it's interesting because
it only makes this EX exemption for
certain business models that's not the
free market the free market would not
say this group is Exempted from this
requirement but this group is not that
isn't the free
market so I would like you to please
press the green button to support the
committee recommendation of itl thank
you the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate unhal
Bill 1044 this is a roll call
V the motion before us is majority
report of inexpedient to legisl and
House Bill 1044 this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
kushman for parliamentary
in thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that our current medical system is
broken and patient satisfaction is at an
all-time low and if I know that we need
alternative options for consumers and
healthcare workers and further if I know
that competition and open market Market
promote the best service at the best
prices would I now please press the red
button so another motion could be
made chair recognize the representative
kerk for parliamentary inquiry thank you
Mr speaker so if I know that our
critical access hospitals run on Raisor
thin margins and they require a payer
mix that includes private pay in order
to maintain the revenue losing services
such as 24-hour full service OB
emergency rooms and abstral services
which are critical particular in our
rural areas and if I know that skimming
off those higher paying patients would
have a significant negative economic
impact on our critical access hospitals
leading to closures of obstetrical
services and of critical access
hospitals which are needed to provide
timely care in our rural areas and if I
know that this bill will decrease access
to health care and will not drive down
the cost of health care and if I know
that this bill is actually thinly veiled
protectionism for facilities that use
just one business model would I then
press the green button to vote Yes to
support the 14-7 committee vote to itl
this Bill thank
you the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
1044 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
do you want to change the of
this
was
that if all members president had an
opportunity to
vote house will attain to the state of
the
vote
need to state state the result first 175
171 voting yay 172 voting
nay the motion
fails for what reason do the member rise
I move on to pass on HB
1044 the
motion
uh yes sorry with the minority Amendment
and we move ought to pass with the with
the amendment minority
Amendment so the minority amendment
is the minority amendment is 0
n918 printed in house record 10A page
8 are you ready for the question on the
for what reason do a member rise for a
motion Mr
Speaker State your motion I move to lay
the bill on the
table that is a higher
motion the motion is the motion is to
lay requested division House Bill 1044
on the
table
somebody
representative blazic requested a roll
call that is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 1044 War this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative kerk
for a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know what I've
already said about the fact that this is
going to be harmful to our critical
access hospitals and well it is true
that they did survive prior to this uh
requirement in 2016 it's important to
know and if any of you have been dealing
with your hospitals you know that their
survival is rather tenuous and a lot of
hospitals have closed and if I know that
skipping off these higher pay patients
would be a
problem and that this bill again is a
protectionist bill for a small business
model and will harm others because
they're not subjected to the
same uh suspension then I would would I
then vote Yes to table this and not go
any
further do I recognize the
representative L on for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I believe it's wrong to hold
some patients captive just so that we
can have a certain patient
mix and if I believe some patients want
more than the allotted time from the
insurance companies so that they can
more thoroughly discuss their treatment
options with their patient with their
doctor and come to a decision where they
are as the payer are the one in charge
would I then press the red button so we
may continue
you the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 1044 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
Weston representative
Weston
no all members president had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 166 voting yay 179 voting nay the
motion to table
fails Amendment we're back to the
question on the amendment I'll read it
again
0991 H printed in houseal record 10A
page 8 are
you are you ready for the question on
the
amendment a Division I believe I heard a
division a division has been requested
members will take their
seats
roll call has been requested by
representative bisaro it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
house will be in order members in your
seats the question before us is the
amendment minority
amendment to House Bill
1044 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you appros you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
head all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
to the
vote 333 voting yay 10 voting nay the
amendment is
adopted the motion before us
now is The Minority Report of ought to
pass as amended on House Bill
1044 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say say I
I those oppos
[Applause]
nay I I put the hammer down before it
was definitely it was it was
definitely an I
vote right so we have a debate on the
amendment here the
amend am am fails want to L the
okay for what reason does a member rise
for a motion Mr Speaker a state your
motion I move that we lay House Bill
1077 on the table and request a division
vote it's not it's not you haven't said
it yet I haven't I haven't read it yet
representative move things
along little little
premature majority of the committee on
Health and Human Services and ELO FS to
which was referred houseal Bill 1 1077
an act repealing the prohibition on
conversion therapy for minors having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Mark Pearson from
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislator of Joe
Shapiro for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise for a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion I move to lay HB 1077 on the
table motion motion is in
orderable the motion before us is the
table House Bill
1077 a division has been
requested seat members take your
seats representative Bel DeSaro request
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
that's prior
one
the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 1077 on the table this is a roll
call
vote the chair recognizes Joe Alexander
for a parliamentary inquiry um thank you
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know the ban
on conversion therapy was recently
signed into law in 2018 just four years
ago and Mr Speaker if I know that
according to the Trevor Project lgbtq
youth who are subjected to conversion
therapy were reported more than twice
the rate of attempting suicide in the
past year compared to those who are not
not and Mr Speaker if I also know that
any attempt to clarify the ban is an
attempt to roll the ban back would I
then press the green button to table HP
1077 thank you Mr
Speaker the chair recognizes
representative Mark Pearson for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I also know conversion
therapy as it has been defined again and
again in my committee is bad and if I
know that the amendment significantly
rewrites the bill to make it
compassionate and fair straight across
the board and if I know that I have
received numbers of emails from people
in the gay and transgender communities
who have thanked me for this compassion
would I not want to hear about this
amendment this bill so would I not
suggest we press the red button and not
table it thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1077 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
quarter all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the
vote 197 voting yay 147 voting nay
motion to table House Bill 1077
passes
majority of the committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 1080 act
relative to the rights of conscience for
medical professionals having considered
the same report the same with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sen of Mark Pearson from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to rep legislate
representative Lucy Weber and the
minority of the
committee the house will be in
order chair recognizes representative
Weber to speak against the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker what this bill
does is it protects those who do not
want to participate in abortions or
sterilization or artificial
contraception from any discrimination in
the workplace based on that
decision it's titled the rights of
conscience for medical
professionals
now I believe the rights of conscience
should apply to all
people
first in this case doctors and nurse
practitioners already have protection of
the AMA code of methodical ethics and
most
employers make accommodation for those
who object to certain
procedures
secondly which means that for those
medical professionals the bill is not
needed secondly let's look at the terms
of the
bill the definition of medical
professional is so
broad that it includes those who are
Manning the reception desk and those who
clean the floor of a surgical Suite it's
basically everyone who works in any kind
of medical
establishment
the definition is so broad that someone
who wanted to act
maliciously could seek
employment at a reproductive Health Care
Center and
then be hired and then assert their
right of
conscience and what would happen then
well despite not doing the job for which
they were hired they could not be
terminated because the bill says that
termination constitutes
discrimination and what happens if you
discriminate the bill creates a new
right of civil action and the recovery
against the health care center would be
a minimum of
$10,000 plus
costs even if
the
employee was
perhaps asserting the privilege
wrongly that's a lot of burden on what
are normally small
businesses but here's the part that I
particularly object to in this
bill all persons should have a right to
act in accordance with their cons
and sometimes that's difficult people
have lost their jobs over it and people
have died for
it it isn't always
easy and in this case what we are doing
is on the oneand we are affording an
absolute guaranteed clear easy
way for people who believe in one course
of action to act in accordance with
their
conscience they're
protected people who
believe that as a medical professional
as an active
conscience they must help a woman who is
past 24 weeks of a problem pregnancy who
is making the most difficult decision
she will ever make in her life with the
help of her family and her medical
professionals those medical
professionals are currently legally
forbidden for acting in accordance with
their
conscience so on the one hand we have
people whose consciences are
protected and on the other hand we have
peoples whose
consciences have a legal
barrier that is just
wrong I ask you to press the red button
so another motion can be
made representative Mark Pearson has
requested a roll call we're down to our
last speaker is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this is going to be a roll call vote
members take your seats we're down to
the last
speaker J recognizes representative Mark
Pearson thank you Mr
Speaker conscience is a precious
thing I think most of us have seen the
documentaries about the Unspeakable
things that doctors and their staffs
were for forced to do in Nazi
Germany and yet one hears that in
numbers of States medical people are
forced to participate in a procedure
that as they and I understand it is the
taking of an innocent human
life there are numerous places where
abortion is practiced but as a small
portion of what is being done this bill
would allow persons of conscience in
this matter to keep keep their jobs
there not disrupting the facility while
allowing the member will
suspend the member has a right to be
heard member may continue thank you Mr
Speaker this bill would allow persons of
conscience in this matter to keep their
jobs while allowing others to stand in
for them in those procedures
only I've heard several objections to
this bill first these protections are
already there in
law if that's the case then no one has
anything to fear for us making it a bit
more explicit do they we're not adding
anything we're just making these
protections that were told are already
there in the law just a little bit more
explicit it's an abundance of caution a
phrase we've all been
using second we've been told no medical
professional in the New Hampshire has
ever been put in job risk for that you
have not spoken to the people I have
next during the hearing I was asked as
Prime sponsor of this bill would I be
willing to include other medical
procedures and other kinds of
professions thank you to my colleagues
across the aisle for bringing that up my
response is over the summer I should be
happy to work with my colleagues in my
committee who posed these questions so
we can file some bipartisan
lsrs
fourth this bill is signed into law the
objections
say would lead to a reduction in the
number of capable medical people coming
to work here in New Hampshire and thus
our quality of care would suffer we
should discount such fear mongering the
fact is for many years Massachusetts had
a build just like this actually with
tougher penalties and yet continued to
draw good people to practice medicine
and was consistently rated as having one
of high
quality I've discovered that states with
laws like the one proposed here have
drawn many quite capable pro-life
medical staff maybe even we would get
better for allowing such conscience
here and finally it was was suggested
that an individual might join the staff
of a facility where abortion is the main
procedure performed and then once there
start asserting rights of
conscience it does not take much mental
acuity to know that no pro-life person
would choose to work at such a
place I close with a quote about Nazi
Germany made by Martin Neer a German
Lutheran pastor about how people of
conscience have to stand up for each
other even if their issues
differ these are the words that are
found on the US Holocaust
Memorial first they meaning Nazis came
for the Communists and I did not speak
out because I was not a
communist then they came for the trade
unionists and I did not speak out
because I was not a trade
unionist then they came for the Jews and
I did not speak out because I was not a
Jew then they came for me and there was
no one left to speak for me the member
will the member will suspend for a
minute I think I think the testimony is
getting a little bit off base if we
could bring it back to the bill itself
yes sir
people of conscience Mr Speaker need to
stand together and I ask people to stand
with me on this because there may well
be a time next time when I'm being asked
to stand with you thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
ought to P majority report of a to
pass this is a roll call vote members
take your
seats
door's Clos sir
the motion before us a majority report
of a to pass on House Bill 1080 this is
a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that our constitution tells us
that rights ought to be
reciprocal and I know that to favor the
rights of conscience of one group of
people over the rights of conscience of
another group of people is just wrong
would I press the red
button house will be in
order chair recognizes representative
lay on for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know an aspiring doctor
nurse or other health care professional
has very little say in what procedures
they participate in and no law to site
today if they're asked has to violate
their conscience by terminating what
they believe to be an innocent life and
if I know that potential care providers
decide early when they decide to take
Premed classes or not what path they're
going to go down and we don't know how
many future nurses doctors and other
Health Care Professionals don't enter
this profession because they're afraid
that they may have to violate their
conscience in this
way and if I know if those tasks to do
no harm should not have to undergo harm
themselves in order to do their job
would I then press the green button in
order to pass this
bill the motion before us is the
majority report of a to pass on House
Bill
1080 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
speak if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state to the
vote 175 voting a 165 voting a the
committer report is
adopted so for what reason do a number
rise now thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
I move that the very preent remarks of
the last debate be published in the
permanent
journal the motion is to publish the
remarks of the last debate in the
permanent
Journal are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppos
nay the eyes have it Mark will be
printed
majority of the committee on Health and
Human Service is and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 11 180 an
act relative to State recognition of
biological sex we considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen Dennis
acting for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate pres of
Jerry G Cannon for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0959 H printed in house record 10A Pages
17 Mr
Speaker uh what reason does a memor rise
for a motion State your motion I move to
lay House Bill 1180 on the
table
well you give me a minute to announce it
first please thank
you
that is a proper motion a roll call has
been requested
by represenative gon is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote members take your seats this is a
roll call
vote
the motion before us is the table H Bill
1180 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes represent of Canon
for a parliamentary
in thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker fellow
Representatives over the past three
years we have heard a
bill representative this a parliamentary
inquiry if I if I know over the past
three years years we have heard similar
bills about transgender people in
sports in the past two years those bills
have gone
nowhere
because if I
know that the transgender population and
the medical staff working with them as
well as our school systems and even
Collegiate environment are making
changes to the
policies that allow transgender girls to
work to to play and to work with other
transgend and other Straight
girls would you please vote with me and
table this Bill thank
you chair recognizes representative Mark
Pearson for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that 60 years ago title n
was put into law so that girls could
compete with boys women with men in a
much more equal way than they had
before and Mr Speaker if I know that we
are seeing an increased amount every
time this bill comes by there's more and
more and more cases of champion girls
who are now
losing to people who as on mail teams
didn't win much at all and Mr Speaker if
I know that this uh billas not telling
schools what to do but allowing them to
have their local
decisions would I now not press the
button against tabling thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is a
tabling motion on House Bill
1180 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're Pros you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
for
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attain to the state of
the
vote 167 voting yay 169 voting nay the
tabling motion
fails we're back to the
amendment which is
0959 H printed in house record 10A page
17 the chair recognizes representative
Mark Pearson to speak against the
amendment
thank you Mr Speaker when this amendment
was first crafted it represented
knowledge that we had having spoken to
Correctional
officials and since then however we have
learned that in a few places around the
country certain laws have been put in
place and with that has come the kind of
problems that occur when fixed laws
replace flexible policies we want to
preserve what we have now in New
Hampshire with our flexibility because
one-sized is not fit all inadvertently
the amendment will weaken this we've
just discovered this and so I am
strongly suggesting we vote no on this
amendment Z gold has requested R call is
that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently
seconded this will be a division vote
members take your seats
e
the question before us is the adoption
of the amendment 0959
H this is a division vote the chair
recognizes Mark Pearson for a
parliamentary
inquiry
okay thank you Mr Speaker and pardon me
for the confusion um once again my Pi is
if I know that the amendment when we
first put it together was brilliant and
if I know subsequent knowledge that has
come to us have said that this could be
counterproductive I would would I not
press the red button against the
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker J recognizes representative gay
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know the goal of this
amendment is to protect women's
sports and and if I know this bill
without the amendment could allow
carding or blocking trans people from
public
bathrooms and if I know this bill
without the amendment could also
complicate the job of New Hampshire
Corrections who already must follow
Federal requirements for safe
incarceration under the prison rape
elimination Act of 2003
are priia as they call it and if I know
that women and girls participating in
sports with trans women teens and adults
deserve to compete against people whose
an transition started before they
reached male strength as advocated by
Caitlyn
Jenner then wouldn't I support this
amendment by pressing the green button I
request a division vote thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the vote
on the amendment 0959 H to House Bill
1180 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
look
repres
Nelson I'm sorry
represent
representan
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
howo attend the state of the
vote the amendment
fails we're
moving the question now is on a to pass
the majority of ought to pass chair
recognizes representative Tanner
you thought you were through with
me um thank you Mr Speaker I guess
they're coming for me so this bill is
all about discrimination plain and
simple the few transgender children who
participate in sports vary an athletic
ability size shape and as much as other
youth do some you youth have outstanding
athletic ability some not so
much gender identity shouldn't play a
role in the opportunities that we give
students in all activities and courses
we offer in school including
Sports there are governing bodies at all
level of sports competition that regulat
Seasons rules and eligibility to
participate in
sports at our high school level in New
Hampshire it is part of the New
Hampshire inter Scholastic Athletic
Association this Association that
oversees all high school competition in
the state has concluded that it would be
fundamentally unjust and contrary to
applicable state and federal laws to
preclude a student from participation on
a gender specific sports team that is
consistent with the public gender
identity of that student in his his or
her school and
Community local schools are charged with
verifying that the school district has
determined that the expression of the
student's gender identity is Bonafide
and not for the purpose of gaining an
unfair advantage in competitive
Sports if you think a high school boy
would put on suddenly put on a skirt and
try out for a girls team um it doesn't
just doesn't happen in high school I
taught in high school for 30
years School sports at all levels should
be centered on inclusion education and
participation there's ample evidence
that an opportunity for adolesence to
participate in sports results in
positive outcomes such as better grades
better work in class
self-discipline higher educational and
occupational aspirations and improved
self-esteem youth learn a lot of lessons
in sports I coach for many years they
learn to get better to have a role on a
team they learn sportsmanship leadership
hard work and they learn to be gracious
in
winning and to be resilient in the face
of defeat which some of us could take a
little lesson on um this is all
discrimination okay it's not about
safety issue um I taught for long time
co-ed High School physical education and
for over 30 years I had no concerns with
safety it's not about co-ed competition
we had co-ed competition in in classes
and um there were as many girls that did
well as boys it's not about fairness
which is an elusive term when your
tallest basketball player on my team was
5'4 and the other team had a 6 foot
center because there will be differences
and not related to gender identity it's
not about winning and losing because
eventually you meet some team or person
who will be better than you worked
harder or just had a lucky
day um NCAA and the Olympic Committee
where competition is a little bit higher
have other rules and regulations but um
they also let transgender people
identify and play in
sports um as
so this bill is giving permission to
schools and governmental agencies this
bill to deny a young person the ability
to participate based on their gender
identity their authentic self who they
think they are how they feel and that is
wrong to deny that as a country as New
Hampshire we have made our
non-discriminant law laws a statement
that how New Hampshire treats people in
protected classes and transgender people
are in a protected class I believe that
discrimination is wrong and that
everybody should have the ability to
succeed in our public schools and life
everybody don't come for them thank
you chair recognizes representative
Weber thank you Mr Speaker we had an
amendment that took away 2/3 of a very
bad Bill but that failed so I'll tell
you about the 2/3 of the very bad Bill
that
remain one of the things that one of the
areas that people would be allowed to
assign people only to their biological
sex if they chose to do that is in the
prison
system and the rationale for that
was uh trans
transgender women who had not completed
their transition being in prison with
females so here's the
problem what we should be doing for our
prison population is making sure that
absolutely everyone is safe every single
prisoner we know that because we just
had the bill about the youth development
center we need to keep everybody be safe
and the way of doing that is not
assigning somebody who is partway
through a transition from male to female
back to a male
prison that's not
safe the other thing is that it is not
fair to put all the burden of
safety on transgender people what we
ought to be doing in the prisons is to
ensure the safety of all the
prisoners and that is being worked on
with prison
policies
and their policies of how people are
housed which takes into account and
recognizes their gender identity without
forcing them to relinquish
it so that's we we had very strong
language from uh both I believe somebody
who is a superintendent of Corrections
in one of the counties and also from the
Department of Corrections at the state
level that this the provisions of this
bill are going to make their lives
infinitely more
difficult so that's one thing the other
section that's still in the
bill is the inclusion of what was called
areas of intimate
privacy you know what that sounds like
to me that sounds like a bathroom bill
do you remember what happened in North
Carolina when North Carolina passed a
bathroom bill it wasn't pretty people
actually pulled out athletic
competitions and all kinds of other
things because they had gone down that
road and I know that people are going to
tell me well this just permits people to
do it it doesn't
require but here's the rub with that if
you permit people to
discriminate in all three of these areas
Sports prisons and places of intimate
privacy then a transgender person who is
assigned
unfairly to a place for their biological
sex will no longer have the protections
against
discrimination that they now have
because we just removed them in this
bill and there will be no recourse for
them so for those reasons because this
bill is now back to its original and
exceedingly flawed
form I ask you to press the red button
and itl so that another motion can be
made thank you does member yield the
questions no remember it does not
yield chair recognizes representative
Canon thank you Mr
Speaker so what is our purpose here are
we putting in
legislation to control a very small
portion of our
population our transgender population
for everyone is about onethird of
1% of our entire
population of that only about
500 members are
students most of those students are
there to get an
education very few of them are there to
participate in
sports and it's very rare when one of
those
students is a
superstar I understand we have a
need to make Sports Fair between
transgender
girls and and CIS girls is the
terminology our schools are aware of
this
the agencies the the athletic
associations are aware of this the ioc
and the NCAA are aware of this and
they've been putting in place
policies to help both the
transgender girls and the trans and the
straight girls play in the same
Sports
in the medical
community they've
identified medication that allows
students it it allows people to block
the hormones of students of young people
from proceeding through
puberty these transgender girls who who
are taking these puberty blocking
drugs grow at the same rate
as their
girlfriends in the
community they don't grow to be the same
as every other
male most of these girls won't
start estrogen therapy until they're 18
years old up until that time they won't
have testosterone in their system they
won't be
growing at the same rate as other boys
and they won't have some of the impact
as far as their skeletal strength and
muscle muscular structure as other
boys there are a number of
organizations that are defining what the
policies
are for transgender girls and
sports first off in the school system
the uh namp Schoolboard Association has
put policies in place for transgender
girls to be in school systems Ed to get
an education just like everyone else
they don't touch
on Sports the sports area is left up to
the New Hampshire inter Scholastic
Athletic
Association that Association has defined
a rule that a transgender student that
wants to play in sports needs to be
registered as a girl or a boy depending
on the gender they identifies as at the
beginning of entering high school with
the full support of their
parents and a plan for them to
grow if they are participating in sports
on on a girls sports team they have to
stay participating on a girls sports
team if they grow and they're
participating on a boy sports team they
have to stay on a boy sports team they
can't cross over between those those two
genders in the
NCAA they just
released in
February a policy concerning transgender
girl in sports in the Collegiate and
Inter
Intercollegiate uh environment even the
ioc the Olympic
Committee has
similar policies these policies
require that a transgender
athlete has to start getting tested for
their testosterone levels so that they
may compete at the same level as other
girls that policy has just gone into
place and um it it's going to start with
one test a year and it's going to go
next year to two tests a year so they're
going to keep track
of the hormone levels to make sure
they're providing a safe environment for
transgender girls or women and other
women in the sports
environment
these are only a few of the
organizations that are working with the
transgender Community to provide a Level
Playing Field for for the environment in
which they work and play
in this bill that's been
introduced is on the the bleeding edge
or the Leading Edge of what is already
happening in in other places and it's if
we implement this
bill it's ignoring that this work is
already being done in other areas and it
may be more appropriate to be done by
other associations and organizations
that are working with transgender people
rather than putting in something at a
statute that will negatively affect
future transgender women or transgender
men that are just trying to live their
life like everyone else on a Level
Playing
Field
please vote red on this Bill thank you
does a member yield to
questions no member does not
yield we're down to the final speaker
this is representative gold has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently
seconded for what reason does a member
rise I'd like to make a motion State
your motion
table we have we have intervening
business Motion in order the motion is
in
order we've had inter bu we've had we've
had intervening business so the motion
is in
order the motion is
table
so Leon will do the
pi representative Mullen you're doing
the
pi
house will come to
order we have a request for a roll call
by representative B DeSaro is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
on the tabling motion that is what is
before us now
oh
the house will come to
order the motion before us is to table
House Bill 11
180 the chair recognizes representative
Marin for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that since the last tabling
motion this bill has changed
tremendously and that it now includes
safety issues in prison privacy issues
in bathrooms as well as Global
discrimination issues and if I believe
that tabling this bill sends a message
to New Hampshire about our position on
discrimination would I please press the
green button in favor of the tabling
motion thank
you chair recognize the representative
Lon for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr
Speaker if I know that NCAA and Olympic
standards for transgendered athletes
require the recognition of biologic sex
in order to respect the rights of the
transgender athletes and Those whom they
compete with and if I know that Circuit
Court ruling
have hinged upon whether or not the law
in a particular State recognizes the
state's role in recognizing biologic sex
in order to make these
distinctions would I then press the
green button to sorry the red button
thank you
sorry um when I then press the red
button in order to allow our state to
continue to recognize biologic sex so
that we can make sure that we are not
discrimin irating against people and we
can recognize their unique
individuality and their specific
needs it is a parliamentary
inquiry the motion before us is the
tabling motion on
hb180 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
f
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attend this St of the
vote 175 voting yay 167 voting nay the
tabling motion
passes
we're going to we're going to the the
sandwiches are all set
downstairs the New Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association has graciously
stepped forward to sponsor our meal
option this
evening let's take a moment to thank
[Music]
them
I'm not
done we have a variety of sandwiches and
wraps from The Works Cafe in conquer
downstairs in the cafeteria we also have
chips and cookies again we ask you to
only take one portion at a time to
ensure everyone at least gets one and
then go back for
seconds important please enter the
kitchen on the side of the cafeteria to
get your food then you can make your way
to the guing area members lounge or any
other area to each of your to eat your
sandwich having dinner is meant to keep
you
here please be back here by
6:45
order members take your
seats members take your
seats
majority of the committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill
1347 an act relative to licensing
requirements for Health Care Facilities
that operate on a membership based
business model having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and a recommendation to Bill
ought to pass with Amendment Senator
Leah kushman for the majority of the
committee minority of the
committee unable to having considered
the same and being unable to agree with
the majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jerry kerk for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise for a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion move to
table the motion is proper the motion
before us now is to table House Bill
1347 are you ready for the are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and 1347 is laid on
the
table
Joy the committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred houseal Bill
1369 an act relative to covid-19 health
and safety policies at New Hampshire
performing act venues consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment sen of
Jerry kerk for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having consider considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
sen Leah kushman for the minority of the
committee the chair recognizes
representative
kushman i' would like to make a motion
for what state your motion I would like
to uh motion to table
1369 that is a correct motion the motion
before us is to
is to table House Bill 1369 a division
has been requested members roll call has
been requested is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
yeah
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
1369 this is going to be a roll call
vote the chair recognizes representative
blazic for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that there is nothing in
statute that currently prevents anything
that this bill seeks to codify and if I
know that we should not waste our time
on unnecessary legislation that does
nothing more than add new laws to the
books with no purpose and if I know that
Performing Arts venues have been setting
their own covid policies this entire
time I would now vote green to table
this
bill J recognizes representative kerk
for parliamentary
inur thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
it is true that facilities of venues can
do this but they have been challenged
with people saying that you do not have
the right to set your own protocols and
them setting their own safety protocols
for the safety of their patrons and for
their employees is a business decision
which they should be allowed to make on
their own and if I know that if they do
not honor the requests of the artist
that artist can take their business to
another venue perhaps across the border
to a Southern state state just bordering
us to the South and we lose that
business and if I I know that many
patients will feel much more comfortable
to go into a setting if they do know
that their safety is being respected and
therefore it can be a marketing move in
addition to their own Independent
Business decision and if I know that
what this bill does then is
affirms affirms the fact that they do
have the authority to set their own
business policies with regard to various
protocols for protection for
communicable diseases would I then vote
against this tabling motion thank
you the motion before us
is table House Bill 1369 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you oppos you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
e
if all members present have an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 177 voting yay 146 voting nay House
Bill 1369 is laid on the
table
for what reason does the member rise I
would like to make a
motion we have nothing in front of us
yet it's to bring something up I would
like to motion to print the remarks on
House Bill
1180 I'm sorry I to put the remarks in
the permanent Journal which for for what
for House Bill 1180 House Bill
1180 the motion
is the motion is to put the remarks for
House Bill 1180 in the permanent
Journal
11ks any other print marks already up
there
the motion before us is to print the
remarks from the debate on House Bill
1180 in the permanent Journal are you
ready for the
question a division has been requested
members take your
seats
the motion before us is to print the
remarks
of House Bill 1180 in the permanent
Journal this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representes representative
Lam represent
[Music]
Massa thumb up or thumb down
please
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 183 voting yay 150 voting nay the
marks will be
printed no
debate committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred Health Bill
1379 act Rel relative to the Department
of Health and Human Services rul making
Authority regarding immunization
requirements considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment sen Jim klat for
the
committee the amendment is 0844 H
printed in house record 10A Pages 54 and
55 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppos
nay the eyes have it an amendment is
adop adopted question before the house
now is on
the motion of ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 1379 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor Vision has been requested members
take your
seats who requested a roll call Senate
blazic requests a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
L you
doing
are you doing a pi
representative representative kerk are
you doing a pi
CLE my apologies I I was forgot that I
was not number two wait what not not yet
oh not
yet
the motion before us is ought to pass
with
Amendment the chair recognizes
representative
kerk for a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill removes the authority of the
commissioner of
DHHS to be able to add
by rule various immunizations that may
be necessary to be
done and that's done very rarely it's
only been three over about 20 years and
the last one was done in 2003 so it is
not something that is done in a
light-hearted fashion and if I know that
the commissioner doesn't do this on
their own but instead they do it in
consultation with the epidemiologist
many other people and uh National
guidelines uh would I then vote against
this bill so that we could maintain the
policy that we have had of having the
commissioner have the flexibility to be
able to respond to public health issues
as needed thank
you chair recogniz the representative
Lon for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that today childhood
immunizations are split between laws and
rules and what this bill does as amended
is to provide a pathway so that all the
mandated vaccines will come to a vote of
the legislature and if I know that this
preserves a pathway for a onetime a
permission for 20 months for anything
that is voted on and approved by the
oversight committee so that we can
respond to emergencies would I then
press the green button to pass this
bill motion before
us is ought to pass with Amendment on
House Bill 1379 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Woodcock of all members president had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to the state of
the
vote 169 voting y 164 voting a committee
report is
adopted the major committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
to which was referred House Bill 1409
act relative the age at which a minor
may receive a mental health treatment
without parental consent having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment s Lucy Weber for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate Senator
Mark Pearson for the minority of the
committee I Rise to table the uh Bill
okay we weren't I didn't know what you
were looking for so you make a motion to
table pres Pearson has made a motion to
table House Bill
1409 roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded is officially
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us is the table H Bill
1409 the chair recognizes representative
Lon for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if we earlier today discussed
how vulnerable children are when they're
sitting in a therapist office and we
respected that
vulnerability and if I know that parents
should be involved in the therapy of
their children and to at least know if
their child is seeing a
therapist and if I believe that this
interferes with not only parental rights
but family relationships would I press
the press the green button to table this
bill chair recogniz is representative
Weber for a parliamentary
inquir thank you Mr Speaker if I agree
that parents should be involved but I
know that there are many parents who are
either disengaged or unable to engage
and do not look after their children and
if I know that by age 16 a child a minor
can consent to sexual activity much as
we wish they wouldn't and to uh be
treated for a sexually transmitted
disease and TR and treated for drug
abuse and substance
abuse and if I know it makes no
sense to wait till a minor is addicted
before we give them help so it would be
better to allow them mental health
treatment where a counselor might help
them connect with their family and
repair the damage to the family
structure would I now push the red
button to allow this bill which passed
the committee with a bipartisan majority
to go forward thank you Mr
Speaker qu the motion before us is the
tabling motion on House Bill
1409 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're appros you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the
vote 171 voting yay 163 voting nay House
Bill 1409 is laid on the
table okay Mr Speaker this one we have a
majority
Amendment no problem on the majority
Amendment
Andes what reason to memorize to make a
motion State your motion I move to
remove HP 1264 from the table and I
request a roll
call she wants some removal from the
table 124 remove from
table
speak
Pi against Pi
against you have an inquiry
representative she's requested a roll
call a roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call
vote the motion before us is to remove
House Bill 1264 from the
table
the motion before us is to remove House
Bill 1264 from the table this is a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative Reed for parliamentary
inquiry okay both have waved off the
Parliamentary inquiries we will go right
to the vote if you're in favor of
removing 1264 from the table you will
press the green button if you're opposed
you will press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Peterson
if all members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 116 voting yay 219 voting
nay 1264 stays on the
table
so no debate on the majority Amendment
she's offer the minority
Amendment majority of the committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which was referred House Bill
1439 act relative to Hospital visitation
policies having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment pres
Erica lay on from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Lucy weather for the minority
Weber for the minority of the committee
majority committee amendment is
10298 printed in house record 10A page
59 are you ready for the question all
those in
favor all those in favor say I I those
oppos
may you guys have it the majority
amendment is adopted the chair
recognizes representative Weber to offer
minority Amendment 0946 H printed in
house record 10A page
60 thank you Mr
Speaker we all agree and we heard
heart-rending stories and all of us have
life experiences that lead us to the
conclusion that okay
everyone who is in hospital deserves the
support and care of their loved
ones and we worked very hard on this
bill and we worked collaboratively on
this bill and mo we came together on a
lot of things so I'm I thank my
colleagues for
that the problem is that what we didn't
agree on first of all we we agreed that
a policy should be in the patients Bill
of Rights that it should be the right of
the
patient to have their loved ones with
them when they're in a
facility and we agreed that we would
keep the language from the original
bill that balances the rights of one
patient to have the support and care of
their family or loved ones with the
rights of every other patient to also
have appropriate care appropriate
infection control and appropriate
support that they need so the bill
contains a set of
balances that the presence of
visitors has to
be um medically and
therapeutically uh indicated
that the presence of visitors will not
interfere with the care of
others that visitors engaging disruptive
and threatening or violent Behavior can
be excluded and visitors non-compliant
with Hospital policy can be in included
that's in both bills that's the
balancing that is important here's where
the bills the Amendments
differ in my
Amendment those considerations are put
just in the patients Bill of
Rights in the amendment you just passed
they are also put into the hospital
licensing the facility licensing
statute so
when in the course of a terrible
pandemic or other horrible
emergency the hospital has to balance
these rights and the amendment we just
passed also requires that whenever a
visitor is denied access it must be
carefully charted into the medical
records so at a time when resources are
scarce and risks are
high we are using valuable medical time
to deal with
charting instead of caring for
patients and at a time when hospitals
are are having to make the most
difficult of critical
decisions we are putting their license
on the line if they get it wrong so I
believe that the appropriate thing is to
give the rights to the patient and the
patient Bill of Rights protecting the
rights of all patients and simply leave
it there and adopt the minority
amendment by pressing the green button
thank
you
J recognized representative
Leon thank you Mr
Speaker my colleague from Walpole is
right that it is good to be able to have
patients have visitors it is good for
their health it is good for their
outcome and it is good for their family
members that don't know if they'll ever
see them again in committee we heard
people here in New Hampshire they were
unable to see their daughters that were
my age and those daughters died of Co in
the
hospital
it was worse that nobody knew what to
expect you didn't know what the
visitation policies were you couldn't
find them you didn't know what was going
on why you would be denied and what was
happening with your loved
one the two differences we have are we
put it in the licensing statute with the
majority amendment that we've already
adopted and we make it so that there'll
be a documentation so that we know why
it's been denied it's easy enough to
when you're saying that the patient
coded say the PO patient coded and we
ask the family to leave it's a small
change if you have a significant medical
event you're already documenting it in
the paperwork and this protects both the
patients and their access to their
family members and the hospitals if
somebody's grieved and let's be honest
these times are trying we've all been
trying to survived these last two years
with as little harm as
possible if we stay if we defeat this
amendment and stay with the majority
amendment that we've already adopted
this they will have to have their
policies online and on the wall of every
patient room so that when the patient is
upset or a visitor is upset if they have
to leave the provider can say right here
I'm sorry but this is a risk to another
patient's rights and so we need to ask
you to
leave we'll have transparency we'll have
Clarity and we can move on with the
business of healing so I ask you to vote
against this amendment and press the red
button do a member yield to questions
yes member yields thank you Mr Speaker
uh thank you representative for taking
my question this is something near and
dear to my heart as the chairman of
Veterans Affairs are you aware that here
in New Hampshire we had family members
outside the VA home knowing that their
family member had Co was dying and could
not go in would not let them wear a mask
they had to stay outside while the
member died are you you aware of that I
was thank you for the question I was not
aware of that happening at the VA but I
know that that happened in many
hospitals throughout our
state the question before us is minority
Amendment on
house who requested a roll call Sen
blazic requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your
seats
w
e
the motion before
us is the minority Amendment
0946 the chair recognizes representative
Weber for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that no one is arguing that people
should be
excluded from supporting their loved
ones and if I know that the terms of
these two amendments are basically the
same except for the extra burdens put on
a Health Care Facility at a time of
emergency when resources are scarce
Personnel is scarce time is
scarce and extra burdens will result in
bad Health outcomes to some of the
patients would I now
push the green button to support this
amendment thank
you chair recognizes representative Lon
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if if I know that the patient
Bill of Rights already protects the
right to have a visitor when death is
imminent but that was not always
granted and if I know that a law without
teeth is only a
suggestion and if I know that while a
large step putting this in the licensing
statute may actually guarantee that the
hospitals are transparent about the
policies what I then press the red
button the motion before us is the
minority Amendment 0946
H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
representative
Herbert
repres
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the
vote 158 voting aay 177 voting nay
minority Amendment
fails now the question is on ought to
pass as
amended for House Bill 1439 the chair
recognizes representative
Weber I'll wave off representative Weber
waves
off representative Leon waves off the
question now before us
is the ought to pass as amended motion
majority of motion on House Bill
1439 are you ready for the question all
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay eyes have it committee report is
adopted majority of the committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which was referred House Bill
1455 an act relative to state
enforcement of federal Mand vaccine
mandates consider the same report the
same with a recommendation of Bill a to
pass pres of Mark Pearson from the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate of Jerry kerk for the minority
of the committee chair recognizes
representative
kerk thank you Mr
Speaker well it is with
trepidation but also with respect that I
Rise to speak against your
bill at the hearing a conflict caused by
this bill was identified but it was
never addressed in the committee process
HB 1455 prohibits the state of New
Hampshire and any of its subdivisions
from assisting in the enforcement of any
federal order rule or law which requires
a person to submit proof of vaccination
against
covid-19 as a condition of
employment but this creates a conflict
for the Department of Health and Human
Services because DHHS is a state agency
and it is responsible for confirming
that health care facilities are in
compliance with Federal mandates as part
of the accreditation process of a health
care
facility and this includes compliance
with the CMS mandate requiring covid-19
vaccination of healthare
workers so prohibiting DHHS from doing
their duty of accrediting Health Care
Facilities that'll have impacts it'll
lead to a loss of accrediation of
facilities that leads to a loss of
reimbursement from CMS for Medicaid and
for Medicare patients and ultimately for
termination from Medicare and Medicaid
programs and remember Medicaid provides
the majority of funding for our nurs ing
homes it will also lead to payment loss
of payment from private
insurers the reason is they they don't
pay unaccredited
facilities the loss of reimbursements
will require the state of New Hampshire
or our counties or both to backfill
hundreds of millions of dollars in
funding to keep our hospitals and
nursing homes
open now in January 13 the US Supreme
Court upheld the CM mandate for the
vaccination of healthcare workers they
stayed the lower court injunction and if
you read the text at their decision they
make it really really clear that they
support the CMS vaccine mandate if it
makes it through some appeal process and
comes to them they will still support it
but furthermore there have been no
appeals to that Supreme Court decision
in the two months that have elapsed
since that time so it
stands I do not think that the state of
New Hampshire should Place itself and
our counties in the position of needing
to backfill hundreds of millions of
dollars of funding to keep our hospitals
and nursing homes open so I would
encourage you to press the red button to
vote no on hb1
1455 so another motion can be brought
forth and I would request a division
vote and perhaps also your um
forgiveness
we are down to the last speaker
representative blazic has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats chair recognizes representative
Mark
Pearson thank you Mr Speaker and might I
add thank you Mr Speaker the balance of
power and responsibility ility between
the federal government and the states
has often tilted against that wonderful
balance in shrined in the 10th
Amendment in the 19th century some
northern states passed personal Liberty
laws which made it illegal for citizens
of their states to help enforce the
federal Fugitive Slave Act and in our
day some states uh perhaps different
from us in their political beliefs have
claimed the right to be Sanctuary States
and thus ban cooperation with Federal
authorities regarding illegal
immigrants I've heard this commended
Yesterday by members of the party across
the aisle if we agree with them and such
States then and now not so much exactly
on the specific topic but on the idea of
saying no then the legitimacy of a
mandated lack of cooperation we should
understand is the motivation behind this
bill I know that some other states have
similarly asserted rights on this very
subject matter contained in this
absolutely wonderful brilliantly
conceived and Incredibly written
Bill and they've not lost Federal
reimbursement for Medicare or
Medicaid and in terms of what the
Supreme Court might do
in
1997 the Supreme Court ruled in prince
versus the United States that Congress
cannot make the states enforced the
federal Brady gun control law which
attempted to require local sheriffs or
police to carry out background checks
for the federal
governments I recommend we pass this
bill and stand with other states
Progressive conservative and in between
so that the movement to re res set the
balance between the federal government
and the individual states can continue
to grow I think we should stand together
with all these other states that are
saying to the federal government we are
proudly
American but back
off thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority report of autop pass House Bill
1455 this is going to be a roll call
vote members take your
seats
the motion before us is the majority
report of Auto pass on House Bill
1455 the chair recognizes representative
kerk for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill will prohibit
the Department of Health and Human
Services from accrediting our health
care
facilities and if I know that that loss
of accreditation will place in Jeopardy
the facility revenues from Medicare
Medicaid and private
insurers and if I know that the loss of
Revenue will require the state and the
counties to backfill a couple of hundred
million dollars annually just to keep
our hospitals and nursing homes open and
if I know that it might be a bit of a
stretch to compare slavery with
immunization would I then please press
the red button to vote OTP to vote no
I'm sorry on the
OTP no on the OTP red button so that
another motion could be brought forth
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognizes
representative Leon for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the powers of the federal
government are limited to those
delegated by the
Constitution and if I know that states
have successfully asserted their right
to determine policy on things ranging
from fugitive slaves to immigration
policy to these very same Co policies we
discuss
here and if I want to reiterate the
statement that New Hampshire will not be
blackmailed would I then press the green
button house will be in
order the motion before us is a majority
report of aop pass on House Bill
1455 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 30
seconds in the
voting
[Music]
representative
goling all members present had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote 174 voting yay 159 voting nay the
committer report is
adopted majority of the committee on
health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which was referred House Bill
1481 started well I've already reading
the report right now so pardon me let me
finish reading the
report enact repealing the statute
relative to Medical freedom and
immunizations having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate as an era lay on for the
majority of the committee minority of
the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with a recommendation that the
bill ought to pass is of Joe shaal for
the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion uh table the bill
Mark Pearson moves that we table House
Bill
1481 representative blazic has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
e
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
okay the chair
recognizes of Layon for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
know that by tabling this bill we will
protect the medical freedom and
immunizations law which we passed last
year and if I know that this law
protected New Hampshire from mandating
and then walking back vaccine mandates
like we've seen in places to our
South would I then press the green
button to protect the fundamental human
right to give informed consent for any
medical
procedure chair recognizes
representative Shiro for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the medical freedom and
immunization act will exclude critical
Public Health measures if there should
be another deadly surge of
covid-19 and Mr Speaker if I know that
it is time to end the partisan bickering
and find a reasonable balance between
personal choice and public health or the
common good then would I push the red
button so that tbling motion can be
defeated and we can debate this issue
thank you the motion before us is to
table House Bill
1481 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative mle representative
Gordon it's too late I need
down represent
M all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will
attended
house will attend to the state of the
vote 175 voting aay 156 voting nay House
Bill 1481 is laid on the
table majority committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred houseal Bill
1495 FN an act relative to vaccine
mandates for government contractors been
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Dennis Acton for the minor majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate pres of
Lucy Weber from the minority of the
committee the amendment is
103h printed in heal record 10A page 66
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment the chair
recognizes representative
Weber okay into the weeds we
go the bill is filed
forbid the state or any of its political
subdivisions so your towns your County
nursing homes all of that stuff uh from
enforcing any federal vaccine mandates
with respect to government contract
people receiving government
contracts and
immediately thank
you
immediately when we started listening to
this we ran up to the usual problem what
one of the things that the state might
be doing is the licensing of hospitals
and nursing homes and they are
contracted with the federal government
to enforce certain federal mandates
because of the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid and the majority Amendment
actually recognizes this might be a
problem and carved that out as an
exception to their Amendment so that was
was a plus with the
amendment on the other hand the
amendment also broadened the
state's uh prohibition from enforcing
any mandate or seeing any
documentation on any business at all in
the state of New
Hampshire the concern that I have with
that is that we already knew there was a
problem in one Health Care area with
that
and we on the Health and Human Services
committee do not know what other
conflicts we are creating with the
breadth of this bill as it was amended
or what is going to come to
seconded this will it is sufficiently
seconded this is going to be a roll call
vote members take your
seats chair recogniz the representative
Lon thank you Mr Speaker I think we all
know that last fall a lot of bills were
filed because we weren't sure what this
year would
bring this amendment distills down a
bill that was filed to some of the very
core ideas the fact that the state
should not be requiring businesses to
act as their enforcement arm this
doesn't prohibit businesses from making
their own choice and those businesses
that have different rules or regulations
upon them probably have a reason to
check on their
own so that they can comply with
whatever they believe is in their best
interest what this bill Amendment this
bill is amendment does is it says that
the state and any subdivision can't
require a business to check for
vaccination except for the childhood
immunization rules because if we ban
that we'd get rid of child care and we
don't want to do
that it also says that we can't to ask a
business to check for documentation of
vaccination status so we don't end up in
the
situation where in New York City
McDonald's was turning away customers
from eating inside the building because
they weren't
vaccinated and we have a carve out here
we do have a carve out that says that
this shall not apply to State agencies
certifying a medical facility or private
or or provider
which is subject to a valid and
enforcable Medicaid or Medicare
condition of participation that imposes
a vaccination
requirement this bill is simple it makes
it so that businesses won't be the
enforcement arm of the state so I ask
that you pass this bill by pressing the
green
button motion before us is to ought to
pass as amended on House Bill
1445 this is a roll call vote vote
members take your
seats
the motion before us is the majority
report of aut passes amended on
1445 this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative Weber for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill is originally filed don't only with
um folks with government contracts
and that the amendment broadened it to
include any business in the
state and if I know that we already
found one problem that was fixed in an
amendment but we don't know what other
problems lurk out there because people
didn't have notice to come and tell us
about them would I now press the red
button so another motion could be made
thank you Mr Speaker J recognizes
representative Mark Peterson for a
parliamentary
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
overburdening businesses with being
state enforcement agencies and that a
state mandated Banning of individuals
seeking to enter commercial
establishments has not worked well at
all in those states that decreed those
mandates and if I know that the
amendment to this bill which we just
passed has made it such that we will now
be voting only on commercial facilities
and not on medical ones would I not now
press the green button to ensure a good
balance between freedom and
responsibility thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is a
majority
report as amended on House Bill
1445 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote house will attend to the state of
the
vote under 179 voting aay 153 voting nay
committer report is
adopted
majority committee on Judiciary to which
was referred cacr
18 house will be in
order an act relating to reproductive
medical decisions providing that the
state shall not infringe or unduly
inconvenience the right of reproductive
medical decisions having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Janine n for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to
pass representative Rebecca McBeth for
the minority of the
committee for what reason as a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
make a motion State your motion I'd like
to table this
bill that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table cac1
18 roll call roll call has a roll call
has been requested is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us is table cacr
18 this is a roll call
vote the chair recognizes representative
na for a parliamentary inquiry thank you
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill will
take two-thirds of those present in
voting to
pass and Mr Speaker if I also know that
we're not likely to get that so let's
just save some time and press the green
button and table this thank
you chair recn as representative query
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I
believe reproductive justice meaning
that all people regarding of race class
or gender have the right to make
autonomous reproductive decisions and
should have the resources and support to
do so and if I know that that the
Vermont house recently moved to put
protections for Reproductive Rights into
their state constitution and with
attacks on both the national and state
level we must protect this human right
if I know that the overwhelming number
of New Hampshire constituents regardless
of political party are pro reproductive
Freeman freedom and deserve to weigh in
on this topic would I go ahead and vote
against the tabling motion thank
you the motion before us is the table
cacr 18 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
s
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 175 voting a57 voting aay cacr 18's
laid on the
table
house will be in
order majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill 1014 an act allowing public
meetings to be conducted virtually
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate pres of Mark
McLean for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority a report with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment sen of Alexis Simpson for the
minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion St motion a motion
to table it is a proper
motion the motion was to table House
Bill
[Music]
1014 division AIS division has been
requested members will take their
seats roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
you
the motion before us is a table
1014 House Bill 1014 chair recognizes
representative turot for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that under rare
circumstances our current rsas allow a
public body to permit a member of that
body on a rare exception to participate
by electronic means and if I also know
that the changes propos in HB
1014 contain new Provisions that would
make the 91a rsas cumbersome inefficient
and in most cases completely unworkable
in both small and large public
bodies and if I also know that inperson
face-to-face meetings by the public body
as well as the inperson participation by
the public for hundreds of years has
been and should continue to be the
predominant way of conducting the
people's business would I now press the
green button and support the majority
recommendation of itl thank you Mr
Speaker chair
recognizes
table chair recognizes representative
page for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that HB 1014 will promote citizen
engagement with their local government
officials and therefore strengthen our
representative democracy by allowing
them to participate remotely in public
meetings an incredibly popular idea
among Granite Staters and if I further
know that this bill protects local
control by simply providing guidance and
not a requirement for a government body
seeking to implement a remote option
what would I then press the red button
and allow for a debate to be to
occur thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is a
tabling motion on House Bill
1014 this is is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 175 voting a 155 voting a house
bill
1014 is laid on the table
majority of the committee on Judiciary
to which was referred H Bill 1073 in act
repealing the right to no exemption for
attorney client work product considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
senat Kurt walper for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Rebecca McBeth for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is 0689 printed in house record 10A page
10 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say
I those oppose
nay the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted majority committee on Judiciary
to which was referred House Bill 111 an
act relative to a forfeiture of personal
property consider the same report the
same with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass sen of Mike Sylvia for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen Douglas traia for the
minority of the
committee the motion before us is ought
to pass are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the committee report is
adopted
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 11007 an act
establishing a committee to study the
rental or lease of housing to a person
who has pets having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate pres of Joe Alexander for
the
committee chair recognizes
representative Horgan to speak against
the committee
report also be in order
the house will be in
order for what reason is a member rise
to make a motion State your motion I
move to lay HB 1107 on the table that is
a higher priority motion the motion is
to lay house bill 11007 on the table are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay no
the eyes have it and house bill 11007 is
laid on the
table house will be in
order committee on Judiciary to which
was referred House Bill
1133 act prohibiting the termination of
a lease during the sale of real property
cons consider the same report the same
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate sen of
Joel Alexander for the
committee motion before us is the motion
of inexpedient to legislate are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted the house will be in
order majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill 120 an act relative to notice of
rent increases in residential rental
property and considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate Senate Michael Sylvia for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative majer Smith
when minority of the
committee what reason does a member
rise make a motion Mr State your motion
a motion to
table is a proper motion the motion to
table has been made for House Bill
1,200 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppos
nay eyes have the eyes have it and House
Bill 1200 is laid on the
table Joy the committee on Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 1291 an
act prohibiting discrimination against
tenants holding certain vouchers for
purposes of renting dwellings consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Joe Alexander from the majority of the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass s of Cam Ken Kenny
for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion to table
is a proper motion the motion to table
House Bill
1291 are you ready for the
question a division has been
requested members take your
seats roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
okay
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
1291 chair recognizes representative
mlan for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that New
Hampshire is hip deep in the middle of a
huge housing crisis if I know that we
need to be encouraging more landlords to
enter into the market and not placing
new burdens that would push them out of
the market and if I know that hb1 1291
would forcefully drive all landlords
into participating in the federal
Section 8 Housing Voucher Program
whether they wanted to or not and thus
require that they unwillingly enter into
contracts that they had no say in and if
I believe that that would actually
reduce the housing inventory would I now
press the green button to table this
Bill thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognizes represent marjerie Smith for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker knowing
that there are at least a few bills that
are too important to dismiss by
tabling and Mr Speaker knowing that the
Section 8 housing program makes it
possible for people who could not
otherwise have access to decent housing
and knowing that for landlords it's a
guarantee that they're going to be paid
because the money comes not necessarily
from the uh the tenant but from the
government would I now vote no on
tabling so this body could take one
small step to help address the problems
of housing in this
state the motion before us is the
tabling motion on House Bill
1291 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
representative
to represent MC
Williams represent MC
Williams all members present had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to stay to the
vote 179 voting a 148 voting nay House
Bill 1291 is laid on the
table majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill 1389 FN an act establishing a
superior court land use review docket
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation to be Bill
be referred for interim study Senor
majer Smith for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Senator Mark McLean from the
minority of the
committee the motion before us is the
committee report referred for interim
study are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppos
nay the eyes hav't and committee report
is
adopted
the committee on Judiciary to which as
referred House Bill 1425 FN an act
relative house will be in
order an act relative to The Taking of
real property by eminent domain having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass sen of Mark McLean for the
committee sen blazic has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote m members
take your
seats
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 1425
FN this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representes representa
for
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 179 voting aay 150 voting aay
committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on Judiciary
to which was referred House Bill 1477
FN act prohibiting abortions after
detection of fetal heartbeat consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate sen of Dian
Langley for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation the bill ought
to pass from is Mark McLean for the
minority of the
committee chair
recognizes representative
mlan thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I'm here to speak in
opposition to the committee
recommendation of itl on hb1 147
77 this is a bill that would ban
abortion after the detection of a fetal
heartbeat as defined as cardiac activity
or the steady repetitive rhythmic
contraction of the fetal
heart one of the things that uh the Row
versus way decision sought to explore
was where life begins and they went and
they looked at The Many religious
beliefs practiced throughout the country
and what they found was there was no
consistency there there was a great
amount of disagreement within those
beliefs and so you couldn't just settle
in on One Faith so putting religion
aside they also went and they found that
doctors had many varying views as well
but one area of agreement however was
that most doctors tended to believe that
life began at some time before birth and
it's for that reason that the row Court
held that the right to abortion was not
absolute and it tried to balance a
woman's right to privacy and the fetus's
right to exist hb1 1477 simply looks at
all the scientific a information that
was not available to the r Court 50
years ago and it asked the question does
Life Begin earlier than the r Court
thought and does that enhance the right
of the fetus to maintain his or her
life we now know a lot more about the
complexities of fetal development than
the RO Court could ever imagine and in
light of that expanded knowledge the
minority felt that while the rights of
the mother are
undiminished the rights of the fetus are
elevated to a point where its status
must be
reconsidered at the stage of Life
defined in this bill where fetal
heartbeat has been detected the minority
felt that the development had Advanced
to the point where the fetus's status as
an individual human entity has been
established and we therefore ask you
overturn the itl motion so the motion of
OTP can be brought forward thank you Mr
Speaker does a member yield a
questions no thank you member does not
yield chair recognizes representative
Langley M didn't
yield
thank
you thank
you House Bill
1477 as
Written House Bill
1477 as written is a near total ban on
abortion within the state of New
Hampshire were this bill to pass it
would essentially and access to abortion
in New Hampshire as it is being on
abortion at around 6 weeks only two
weeks after a woman's first missed menes
a time when many women have not even do
not even know that she's pregnant to put
it in another way this bill could take
away a woman's right to make her own
medical decision before she even knows
that she has a decision to make House
Bill
1477 is while wild ly out of step with
the granite state values abortion Bans
are a deeply held popular view in New
Hampshire instead we've had a long we've
had a long proud bipartisan tradition of
supporting reproductive Freedom the vast
majority of granite Staters believe that
personal private medical decisions
should be between the individual and the
doctor not the individual and
politicians we can all agree
Granite Staters deserve access to the
best medical care available without
shame or government
interference if this bill were to pass
that would no longer be the case for a
woman seeking abortion care passage of
this bill would force a woman who cannot
who can afford an abortion to leave and
go out of state for those women who
could not travel out of state due to
lack of finances or Transportation she
would be forced to remain pregnant
against her
will further this would Rob her of the
trust the guidance and the expertise of
the competent Medical Professional she
had selected when making with her
partner if she Cho so chooses one of the
most intimate and personal of life's
decisions instead instead the decision
would follow a predetermined path that
had been legislatively mandated by
finally we don't have to imagine the
impact of this abortion bill we can
simply look to the state of Texas and
see the Havoc that the abortion bills
that have been created in Texas have
placed on the mental health the Health
Care
system thank you please push the green
button to itl this bill does a member
yield the questions no I do not member
does not
yield
she's moving the
table for what reason does a member Rise
um to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion
and I'd like to speak to my motion my
motion is to table um House Bill
1477 and I'd like to speak to my
motion I can't speak you can do a pi I'd
like to give a pi
okay the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1477 roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded
it is s efficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take their
seats
for
e
the house will be in order the motion
before us is to table House Bill
1477 the chair recognizes representative
Mary Smith for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I
knew that my very distinguished
colleague from straford County would
find a way to pack the house again and
bring everybody in from the anry
room and if I knew that while he was
able to do that there are many members
of this body who at 8:30 in the evening
were not able to be here and register
their position on this very important
vote would I now vote to
table House Bill
1477 with the expectation that in the
very near future perhaps as soon as
tomorrow we would be able to move to
take this bill off the table and have
everyone in the New Hampshire house be
able to vote Yes or No thank thank you
Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
tabling motion on H Bill
1477 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote also will attend to
state of the
vote 185 voting yay 143 voting nay House
Bill 1477 is laid on the
table
majority of the committee on Judiciary
to which was referred House Bill 1490 FN
act relative to equal access to places
of public accommodation regardless of
vaccine status considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass sen of Kurt
walper for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate in a
mark P for the minority of the committee
chair
recognizes represent representative
Paige thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today in opposition to
the recommendation that hb1 1490 ought
to pass under our state's
anti-discrimination statutes this bill
would create a new but undefined
category of protected class vaccination
status in addition the bill would
prohibit places of public accommodation
including Health Care Providers from
denying entrance to someone based on
their vaccination status and also
prohibit them from requiring a person to
use a medical device another undefined
term in the
bill as we contemplate creating another
category of a protected class it's worth
considering the other enumerated classes
already protected against discrimination
to which vaccination status would be
added existing law prohibits
discrimination in public accommodations
based on categories such as age sex
gender identity or race these are
protected because Unfortunately they
have faced a long history of
discrimination and exercising the civil
rights in this light adding vaccination
status as a protected class seems
ahistorical and
misplaced but beyond that it's worth
thinking about the purpose and context
of of the state's anti-discrimination
statute RSA 354a where this bill would
rest if it became law was enacted under
the state's police powers to protect the
welfare and health of our citizens yet
this bill if enacted would threaten
Public Health rather than protect it for
example this bill would be enforcable
against Health Care Providers creating a
scenario whereby these providers could
not require vaccines or even masks
perhaps thus potentially exposing
employees and patients to lethal but
preventable diseases such as
covid-19 indeed at committee Healthcare
Providers testified that the threat that
this bill represents to their ability to
effectively protect their employees and
Patients health and safety surely such a
result is that cross purposes with the
legislative intent of RSA
354a to protect the public safety and
Welfare of our citizens and finally
finally this bill suffers from
significant definitional shortcomings
both vaccination status and medical
devices the operative terms of the bill
are
undefined the Department of Justice
noted that this vagueness would lead to
an increase in complaints under the law
diverting scarce resources to resolving
the meaning and application of these
terms I urge you to oppose the
committee's recommendation thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognized representative
w
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
there's anything we've heard
about today and for the last couple of
years it's
vaccination and and can I be forced to
get it and masks and do I have to wear
them Mr Speaker we looked at
Mr Speaker we looked at this bill can
you hear
me a little closer to the
mic go ahead get any other advice or do
I have to listen to
okay we had other bills that dealt with
this same topic and you've heard a lot
about it today about rights of to be
vaccinated and conscience rights and all
of
that
we chose to bring this one bill
forward dealing narrowly with public
accommodation because we hear a
testimony Mr Speaker of people who
couldn't go buy their
groceries because they couldn't wear
masks for medical reasons the medical
device I I spent quite a bit of time
trying to figure out what kind of
medical devices could apply to
and the mask was the only one I could
come up with so if you can find some
more you can have it all right so so it
applies to masks and applies to
vaccination status and we just believe
that vaccination status is a part of
your personal privacy a part of your
medical privacy and you should not have
to disclose that to use public
accommodations whether it's a bus
or anything else so for that reason Mr
Speaker I recommend we pass House Bill
1490 roll call has been requested by
representative Silber is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your
seats
e
members take your seats this is a roll
call
vote
the motion before us is the majority
report of autopass and House Bill 1490
the chair recognizes representative
Langley for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know adding vaccination
status to New Hampshire law recognizing
vaccine status as a protected class is
an overreach and a questionable
precedent and if I also know defining
vaccine status as a protected class
under the of the Civil Rights Act would
make it impossible for health officials
to monitor disease outbreaks and finally
Mr Speaker if I know adding vaccination
status to anti-discrimination
legislation would limit the
tools and data available to the state's
Public Health efforts in protecting the
state the safety of its
citizens excuse me would I V now vote no
on the committee report of to pass thank
you chair recognizes representative
Sylvia for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
discrimination of any kind
is a horrible
thing if I know that your vaccination
status is a piece of your private
information and further Mr Speaker if I
know that people shouldn't be poking
around and trying to pry your private
personal health information from
you would I then press the green button
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is a
majority report of a
pass on House Bill
1490 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
all members present had an opportunity
to vote houseold attend to the state of
the
vote 161 voting a 170 voting nay the
motion
fails
represent representative Smith moves in
expedient to
legislate um yes you put your the words
right in my mouth Mr
Speaker a question before us the motion
before us is The Minority Report of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1490 are you ready for the
question a division has been
requested representative bisaro request
the roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division
vote
the motion before us is a Minority
Report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 1490 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote house will attendant the state of
the
vote 171 voting aay 160 voting
nay the motion of itl
passes committee on Judiciary to which
was referred House Bill 1519 FN and act
defining religious belief and protecting
it from discrimination having considered
the same report the same of the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Alexis
simpton for the M for the
committee the mo the motion before us is
the committee report of inexpedient to
legislator are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it
committee report is
adopted
majority on the committee on Judiciary
to which was referred House Bill
1625 act repealing the prohibition on
entering or remaining on a public way or
sidewalk adjacent to a reproductive
Health Care Facility considered the same
report the same with a following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate is in a mark page for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative mark mlan from
the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
mlan thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker the minority of the
house Judiciary Committee felt that hb1
1625 a bill repealing the New Hampshire
law prohibiting people from being
present on a public way adjacent to a
reproductive health facility is long
overdue the New Hampshire buffer zone
law was enacted in
2014 and it's modeled after and largely
similar to uh a Massachusetts law that
the US Supreme Court struck down in June
of that year now the Supreme
Court was unanimous in its ruling that
extending a buffer zone from Clinic
entrances was a violation of the First
Amendment rights of those that sought to
protest or offer counseling outside
facilities chief justice Roberts in his
opinion stated that authorities have
many less intrusive ways to deal with
problems outside the clinics and the
committee heard testimony that existing
criminal threatening laws are more than
adequate to deal with most problems that
arise given the Constitution
issues plaguing this law one might ask
the
question why hasn't it been struck down
like the Massachusetts law was struck
down and the reason is simple after more
than 7even years no abortion clinic or
reproductive health facility in New
Hampshire has ever implemented its
Provisions ever as a result no one has
ever had standing to take it to court so
let that sink in for a little bit
supporters of the bill repeatedly
stressed its urgent need as a tool to
keep clinics safe and yet having won the
day they never implemented the law that
they had fought so hard for every effort
at appeal has led to a great outcry that
women and Clinic staff would be
subjected to increased danger if a repal
were successful well guess what the
repeals were never successful they were
always unsuccessful and
still the provisions of the law were
never implemented so let me ask you this
how can removing something that has
never been implemented after 7 years
lead to a sudden increase in
danger in this legislature we should not
seek to burden the state with an
unconstitutional law that looks to
inhibit the right of our people to
peacefully and prayerfully Express
themselves this is especially the case
when the law in question by its ongoing
inaction turns a blind eye to the very
people it purports to serve it's time
for repeal and I hope you will join with
me in overturning the itl motion on this
bill so a motion of autop pass can be
brought forward thank you Mr
Speaker represent ative n has requested
a roll call we're down to the last
speaker is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this is going to be a roll call vote
members take your
seats J recogniz the representative
Paige thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today to speak in favor
of the bipartisan majority
recommendation of the Judiciary that HB
1625 is inexpedient to
legislate as we've heard HB 1625 would
repeal the state's current patient
safety zone law which provides for a
safety zone around reproductive Health
Care
Facilities the bill is premised on the
notion that our current law is
unconstitutional because the US Supreme
Court struck down a restrictive
Massachusetts law there are a few
preliminary points to keep keep in mind
that on their own make this bill